I heard a quote from you our mutual
friend George Mack uh sent me a quote
that said a rich man is anyone who earns
more than his wife's sister's husband
yeah that actually isn't me I wish it
were me because I would have retired on
the basis of that quote happily I think
uh it's what's the what's the chap
called a brilliant American humorist
called The Sage of Baltimore the
Americans will know um no idea he a
fantastic comic writer and I've briefly
forgotten his name right but it is
interesting how um interesting I was
having ation yesterday with someone at a
an addiction clinic in Switzerland which
I can't name I wasn't there as a patient
just in case you I was there a very very
interested Outsider and he said that you
know comparison is the enemy of
happiness that you know one of the
things that seems to be a curse for all
humankind and you've obviously read I
you probably interviewed the author of
the status game have you store yeah yeah
yeah which is a fascinating book because
it's this kind of terrifying invisible
force that drives us and we're in denial
about it and in some ways the game only
works because we pretend we're not
playing the game you see what I mean and
that comes down to other other phrases
about status seeking which is I think
the famous one of Aristotle anassis
where he said that if there were no
women all the money in the world would
be worthless I think he's probably
overstating that I mean you know they
presumably Pleasures to be derived from
sort of jet skiing and i' I'd like to
have one of those Yachts not for the
yacht but just for I know it's not
called parking you know it's called
moing okay but the actual business of
sailing around on one of those Yachts
wouldn't appeal to me at all but docking
the [__] thing that must be an
absolute Joy do you ever watch that guy
called super yacht captain on YouTube no
now what they do when they dock those
things is they actually send up a drone
so they've got an aerial view of the
ship right and then they use the bow
thrusters and the stern thrusters to
actually maneuver the thing in W I mean
you get that now on um cars right you
know the fanciest Range Rover gives you
what appears to be an overhead it
actually I've got the electric car they
tend
to Fantastic car absolutely delighted
with it yeah right have you are you
going to upgrade to something similar
something Poss the macki GT next time
because then I'll I'll be well into a
midlife crisis and so I'll need a car
with stripes on it uh interesting that
you said earlier on I just attributed
misattributed a quote to you there's
something called churchillian Drift did
I teach you about this before which is
where quotes there's also a famous thing
which is called somebody's law which is
that the quote is never attributed to
the original person who said it right
and it also applies to scientific laws
so if you take baze theorem it wasn't
actually Baye it was someone about 50
years earlier who's a blind
mathematician at Cambridge in fact I
can't remember his name appropriate
enough we can all remember baz's name
but we can't remember the person
actually came up with it and so quite
often it's the second
person uh the person who popularizes or
makes famous who actually gets the law
or the discovery credited to them not
the person who is the original
Discoverer well it's a stickiness game
right it's all about who manages to
capture the mem best me and George were
talking about this yesterday all H Menin
right the sage of Baltimore there you go
there we go you know that Americans did
you Tak it's only taken theic's kicking
in he's one of those people who um
probably is you know there are certain
people who are you know much more famous
in America than they are in Britain
undeservedly so because he was
extraordinary yeah what have you learned
about the choice chitecture of online
dating sites and how it relates to
property websites well this is this is
kind of interesting because one of the
reasons one of the reasons I like
working in advertising and marketing is
I think the correct way to solve
problems and to understand what's going
on is really bottom up not top down by
which I mean
um actually open-minded inquiry and
observation of all kinds of things okay
tends then over time patterns start to
emerge and I think the better way what
we try and do in politics in particular
is we start with a theory we then impose
the theory on reality we trumpet the
areas or the scale at which that theory
succeeds and we sweep under the carpet
those areas where the theory basically
fails okay so if you take something like
okay uh if you take something like the
efficient market hypothesis
it probably has an application in a few
fields and those are well celebrated and
measured by economists it's a complete
nonsense to apply um the same rules of a
market to say the property Market or the
dating Market as you do to the market
for a commodity like iron or or
something of that kind okay they're
fundamentally different in particular if
you look at the property Market there's
a problem because when people go and buy
most things you know uh if you went out
to BU by a car I've got to ask about
your car you I'm a big macki Enthusiast
have you gone electric or in Texas does
that get you vilified it will it would
get me killed not in Austin though uh
yeah Austin suff Austin it's
sufficiently Progressive I think I'll
get Camaro a Camaro for my first car in
America uh FYI there's no license
equivalency between the US and the UK
which means that I need to retake my
theory test 18 years after I took it in
American which is weirdly difficult it's
going to be it's all the road signs are
different what does this particular
thing mean all of my knowledge about
roundabouts is totally [__] useless
obviously my car which is obviously
American has an interesting American
feature which is you can set the cruise
control to effectively go at the speed
limit plus or minus X miles hour so it's
using this satav it uses a mixture I
think of satnav and actually Optical
Character recogition reading the road
which does raise the question that
people in residential areas are going to
put up fake s m an hour signs along
their Street streets so that electric
cars all automatically slow to a crawl
how hilarious but um so I imagine you
know you notice that wonderful thing
where people as I predicted were hacking
autonomous taxis in San
Francisco you put a cone on the on the
hood as they'd call it and the thing was
basically immobilized in a state of
complete confusion and I predicted that
I'm proud to say five years ago I said
people will hack self-driving cars and
they'll discover that all you got to do
is put a pattern of weighted balloons on
the road and the things will go
absolutely Dali and sure enough someone
discovered that okay dating sits so
dating sites okay so let's look at
something here which is so to go back to
my original point the market for
property is highly problematic because
what most people do when they buy uh
they look for property to buy is they
work out how much Deposit they have they
then work out how much they can borrow
they add those two together and they
start looking for houses around that
price okay so the basic heris question
they're asking is how much can I afford
and then they start
looking now if you notice we don't buy
anything else like that we don't buy
cars that way okay if you went and said
okay how much money can I raise as a
deposit how much can I borrow people be
driving around in Bugattis and you know
Bugatti Veyrons and Bentleys all over
the place we don't do that with cars we
kind of take a balance on how much
property how much car do I actually need
how much do I care about cars Etc but
because we have this juristic that
effectively property is the only tax
free big bet you can make in your life
okay with huge tax advantages in terms
of the capital gains everybody maxes out
now unsurprisingly people who sell
property have noticed this fact and
consequently property prices go up and
up and up because everybody's
effectively so as interest rates go down
it doesn't make anybody richer it just
means that they set their Target price
for the property they're prepared to buy
even higher than before sellers of
property aren't complete idiots so they
basically put their price up to get
whatever they can get and so
consequently you end up with an absurd
spiral okay so the property Market is
fundamentally unlike say the market for
as I said whether it's iron ore or
indeed whether it's you know uh high
quality energy dink yeah there it is
doing some implausible product placement
it um now it struck me also that there's
a fundamental problem in three things
which actually is the same in all three
cases and it's the market for graduate
recruits the market for first in other
words employees for first
jobs the market for property and the
market for dating okay which is that two
problems when you recruit someone
straight out of University or you
recruit anybody for a job in which they
have no experience at all okay you don't
know anything about them realistically
but you need a proxy so the proxy seems
to have become you know Russell group
University 2 one or above and everybody
uses that as the first stage filter for
their search and everything that doesn't
meet those criteria or everybody who
doesn't meet that those criteria
effectively disappears out of the
marketplace despite the fact that they
may be possessed of unbelievable talents
they just either had a good time at
University or a part of that very large
part of the population who are very very
clever but don't feel motivated doing
academic hypothetical things okay you
know if you think about it I know people
people who are good at chess are
probably quite bright in some respect
but you can't say someone who's bad at
chess is thick right you know my
brother's an astrophysicist he's [__] at
chess right okay um uh you know I mean
they they do actually record games that
sort of Einstein and Oppenheimer played
in The Manhattan Project and they're
kind of okay chess players but they're
nothing amazing right so you know there
are quite a lot of things that are
oneway proxy necessary but not
sufficient in other words exactly
necessary but not or sufficient you know
but but actually not necessary so
actually you know now what's happened
here as a consequence is that we're
automatically just discarding now let's
take dating as a parallel there what's
your first filter okay the HR person's
first filter is two one and above you
know and then they interview them but
but the first filter is that two one and
above they got to have a degree in fact
increasingly I noed my daughter's
generation are doing master's degrees
because even if you got a first class
degree from a Russell un Russell group
University it's that positional good
thing where you create hyper competition
and it's really a kind of peacock's
taale signaling effect okay so what
you're really proving is not ability or
human capital it's just commitment to
the area in which you're invested okay
now in dating sites it strikes me that
what you have I I got married long
before there were online websites and as
a contemporary of Mind said said who
also got married before there was online
dating he said I feel like I caught the
last helicopter out of Saigon you know
genuinely I wouldn't know where to get
started in online dating but what's the
first Criterion you use accept or reject
now I'm assuming here you're a guy I
don't quite know it works slightly
differently I think for women because
obviously the demand is completely
asymmetric okay but it's a still picture
of them and some words of text all
right now how good just as two one or
above is not actually a brilliant proxy
for how valuable an employee this person
will be it's all you've got okay I don't
think a still photograph and a few words
of text uh in any way a proxy for who
you might Forge a long-term relationship
with okay because what you're doing is
you're making a series of decisions
you're going you're working your way
down the decision tree to use the
language of choice architecture and
because every decision you make you're
happy with you think therefore that a
series of seemingly rational decisions
will reach an optimal
outcome but actually I me for example
there are people who are extremely
attractive actresses who wouldn't make
it as a model because their
attractiveness is to do with motion
humor wit pres you know all those things
which matter more in a relationship than
how you look in a static photograph you
know I'm showing my age here but Cameron
Diaz probably wouldn't have made it as a
Vogue model okay but know Jennifer
Anison I don't know okay but what I mean
what I'm saying is what makes them
attractive is a whole mix of things like
humor deportment movement you know
subtle things which cannot be captured
at all in that initial filtration phase
same goes for employment what makes a
good employee cannot really be very well
captured by that initial filtration
phase same goes with property okay which
is what do people do when they look for
property they go okay uh first of all
how much can I afford and they start
looking at that point point then they
ask the second question which is where
is it and how many
bedrooms now all I'm saying okay is that
it seems rational while we're going
through that process it seems perfectly
sensible because each stage we're
filtering what we don't see the dog that
doesn't bark in the night is what we're
rejecting that might be great okay now
here's where the problem really gets
acute okay everybody's going through
this decision tree starting at the same
place and working through in the same
order that's what online Choice
architecture does now if you look at how
people chose houses or for that matter
girlfriends or boyfriends back in the
pre- internet age there was a lot of
noise in the system you know I mean the
conventional British way and the you
know the New York way is you go out with
people and first of all find out how
much they earn as far as I can see okay
I mean dating in New York always strikes
me as like a weird Jane Austin kind of
transactional field okay but in Britain
basically you went to a rugby club and
got pissed with your friend's sister
okay and then you discovered you really
liked each other now it's messy I'm not
suggesting it's optimal there's a lot of
choice you're missing out but everybody
effectively found a house found a
partner in a different way the choice
architecture was different the starting
point was different the initial filter
in many cases people found a house
because they walked past an estate agent
window they drove down a lane and saw a
for sale
side and in many cases they didn't start
seing with 800,000 and down right and it
was messy so people had houses had lots
of opportunities to appeal to people and
partners had lots of different strengths
which they could deploy depending on the
circumstances in which the meeting took
place because I mean guys aren't that
shallow men are a bit shallow but there
are hell of a lot of Personality
features okay now if everybody chooses
according to the same criteria it's a
much less efficient market clearing
mechanism than if everybody's a bit
messy so let's assume that you had you
know I I I mentioned this earlier
because I was talking to a kind of
recruitment firm I said let's imagine
where you had a world where weirdly
everybody's HR uh director was like
oddly prejudiced okay but they're all
prejudiced in completely different ways
you know one person was obsessed with
Hing Oxbridge graduates another person
was obsessed with hiring Jamaicans uh a
third person was obsessed with hiring
scousers okay
over time multiple differing prejudices
or what you might call diversity of
opportunity rather than equality of
opportunity would provide a more
efficient market for talent than the one
we have now which is regimented and
identical and it seems to me there's a
conflict here which is in recruitment
the needs to look fair means you have to
apply the same criteria to everybody
which means as that kind of consistency
of selection spreads out across the
whole of Industry okay it actually means
that there's a ludicrous undersupply of
certain people who meet those initial
criteria while the 50% 80% of people who
don't meet those initial sortation
criteria effectively go to waste yeah
it's like there must hell of of girls
who are single because they just don't
look that great in the still as photo
right now there's a further thing which
is now i' got to be really careful
because my wife's going to watch this
okay but actually you don't want a wife
or a house which appeals to everybody
right if you know if you marry a
supermodel right basically they're going
to run off with your tennis coach and
take your house right what what you want
is someone who's disproportionately
attractive to you yeah all right that's
the sort of game theoretic approach of
house hunting so my my approach to house
hunting I'll stay out of dating because
my wife might be watching this okay is
to some extent a form of and I've often
said that estate agencies would be a lot
better if they actually were forced to
list the downsides of a property as well
as the upsides because the shrewd way to
choose a house is not to say what's my
perfect house it's to say what do other
people hate that I don't mind yes okay
so an example in my case would be next
to a railway line absolute bonus you
know I Love Trains right they stop at
midnight they don't keep you awake i'
never go to bed before midnight anyway
i' actually pay extra to have trains
going past my house okay equally my
children have left school so the school
catchment area can be you know
crackheads academy doesn't bother me
right because okay my kids are 22
right and the other the third one which
would be a massive bonus to me I
couldn't believe my parents-in-law once
didn't buy a beautiful Georgian house
wait for the reason because it was next
to a pub right I think sorry I'm totally
confused here that's a the best Garden
in the world right it's not sissing
Hurst it's a beer garden right because
it's a garden and it's got beer now I
actually knew some people who Liv next
to a pub and they had such a good
relationship with the landlord they
could actually order over the fence so
if they had a barbecue they could just
go you know four points of the
usual now to a lot of people being next
to a pub is an absolute nightmare you
know flight path okay if you're if
you're completely deaf go and buy a
place in the heathow flight path because
it's not going to bother you but it's
going to bother everybody else so the
other thing about this very regimented
mode of choice is that it prevents you
from gaming the
system yes now to be honest what makes
someone initially attractive at first
glance and makes the relationship
enduring okay are not the same thing
they're not the same criteria therefore
using what you might call First Glimpse
criteria in a house in an employee uh in
a potential partner okay in if you're if
you're seriously after a long-term
relationship which after all you are
with a house and you are with an
employee you may or may not be when
you're on an online dating site that
varies okay the first Glimpse criteria
are totally unreliable as a guide to
long-term enjoyment so this why my
wife's going to kill me for this okay
the kind of person you want to marry
right isn't something that everybody
wants it's something the value of which
you only discover on repeated familiar
on on long-term familiarity so you want
what you want is an air fryer girlfriend
or a Japanese toilet girlfriend okay
right not a Corvette girlfriend do you
see what I mean right you want something
which actually you know the value of
fully because over long-term exposure
they're actually technically called in
economics they're called experience
Goods okay and what's interesting about
an experience good is that it's
something the value of which only
becomes apparent with use okay sorry
this is terrible using that economic
term to refer to relationships it's not
the worst thing people have said about
relationships on the internet this we
you're probably right yeah yeah yeah
yeah but that is that is fundamentally
interesting that what the internet has
done that the two things are is that in
many cases the thing it yields up as the
first filtration point is not a very
good proxy to begin with but secondly
and this is I think the worst problem if
everybody is using the same first stage
filter because everybody's on Tinder or
whatever it may be
okay then effectively it's going to
create a totally inefficient market
clearing mechanism because demand
disproportionately goes towards those
people who happen to me those initial
those initial proxy
yeah now that strikes me fundamentally
as a problem in all three of those
markets in other news this episode is
brought to you by element element is a
tasty electrolyte drink mix with
everything that you need and nothing
that you don't it's a healthy
alternative to sugary electrolyte drinks
and it is the best way that I have
started my morning every single day for
over three years now it contains a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium with no
sugar no coloring no artificial
ingredients or any other junk your
adenosine system that caffeine acts on
isn't active for the first 90 minutes of
the day but your adrenal system is and
salt acts on your adrenal system so if
you want to be more awake want to
regulate your appetite curb cravings and
have better brain health this is the way
to start your day head to drink LM
nt.com slod wisdom to get a free sample
pack of all eight flavors with your
first box plus there is a nobs no
questions asked refund policy so you can
buy it 100% risk-free that's drink LM
nt.com
SL modern wisdom did you read Seth
Stevens Dez's book everybody lies so he
was an ex data scientist at Google and
then he did another book called don't
trust your gut oh no I haven't read that
so the second one don't trust your gut
looks at this specific problem it looks
at what is the issue by the way nicotine
plus that is like just the supercharged
yeah I know yeah beautiful what flavor
is that uh this one's I think Cherry I
think oh very good with my cataract I
can't bloody read this
sorry sorry this is this is going to be
the first ever guest Chris has had where
half of our conversation is about
medical problems so sorry that's totally
fine um yeah in his second book he looks
at um people who basically haven't been
priced into the market uh when it comes
to dating uh and um by the way who's
single makes no sense does it if you
actually go around the world and meet
people who are single and meet people
are in relation Highly Educated women
Highly Educated women one of the most
over represented single groups you got
women who can contribute a ton of money
to a household Etc I'm married to Highly
Educated women they pay the
[__] my God my God the arguments
never mind okay but no no but also
because historically effectively this
may change okay so women are more
reluctant to marry down in education
level than men are correct interesting
probably because men are shallower and
they just go well you know 21y old
Barista that can't spell her own name
yeah it's your atrophy wife as I call
them you know very thin second wife yes
exactly my god um but you know you
notice that the people you they have
that very weird breed of people who are
sort of very rich and very very thin you
know right um but but know so I mean
Chris Rock did a whole routine on this
didn't he which was what was it men
can't go backwards sexually women can't
go back in lifestyle was I think the
Chris Rock routine one thing that I
think deserves study
um which is interesting is a huge
generation of um the most successful
comedians are also amateur or you
amateur effectively evolutionary
thinkers aren't they yeah so if you look
at javice absolutely fascinated by kind
of dowin and evolution and so on um
absolutely true of say Andrew Schulz
true of Jimmy Carr um Jimmy Carr
actually wrote that co-wrote that book
with Lucy Greaves the naked jape which
is a absolutely fascinating kind of
investig ation into the evolutionary
origins of
comedy and actually there are a few more
than that I mean you know I think you
can see it in Dave Chappelle you can see
it in Chris Rock a lot of that stuff
there's a huge influence and there seems
to be a significant correlation between
interest in kind of evolutionary
psychology and um comedy well ultimately
it tells us why we are the way we are
right and that is one of the insights to
say the thing that everybody knows but
no one has named or no one dare say yeah
is one of the greatest forms of Comedy
that you can find there was something
else I remember but also I suppose it's
all
about um I mean I suppose you know
recontextualization so comedians are
going to be very very open to different
ways of looking at the world because it
is to some extent The Source you know
that contextual flip is at the root of
quite a lot misdirection exactly um but
it is fascinating because like music we
have this debate what is the
evolutionary function and one of the
things that strikes me as odd is that we
don't look at
comedy uh as a source of inspiration for
wider problem solving so I did an
interview with Jimmy Carr at um ad week
which was a kind of advertising Festival
which by the way is as you must have
found um I mean people like him for
example the what you might call Brain to
mouth speed is extraordinary isn't it
terrifying there's that great phrase in
television which is called brain to
mouth and you know Jonathan Ross or
whatever people like that are very very
good as interviewers because they can
basically form a thought and speak it
more or less in
parallel and I I found that really
interesting in terms of you know talking
to Jimmy Carr because it's rather like
you know you fancy yourself a bit there
was a wonderful thing I saw actually on
I think it was the a299 in East Kent
which was one you know you know they
sort of hotted up citrons which are like
the hot hatch with enormous kind of um
unne necessarily large tail pipes and a
ludicrously large woofer that takes over
the whole of the um uh the boot
and um one of those on the a299 decided
to take on a McLaren F1 okay and I have
to say it was comical to watch the guy
actually you know quitted himself in the
first sort of five seconds reasonably
well but I felt a bit like that you know
talking to Jimmy car because you know
you work in a business you were the
Citron with the big I was the citon with
the unfeasibly large tail pipes okay and
and similarly I've always been in awe of
Andrew Schultz for the the crowd work
just has just has a speed which is just
terrifying yeah yeah m i so someone
asked me the other day um who are the
easiest people to speak to and who are
the most difficult people to speak to on
the show and I definitely find that
comedians are the ones that I need to be
the most switched on for Mark Mark
Norman in particular Mark is so it's
such a game of it's not a game of uh of
tennis it's a game of ping ponging
binging binging it's that it's that kind
of pace and you're right he rides the
crest of now it's oddly a Sam haran sort
of type thing he's just living in the
Perpetual present and just deploying
thoughts as they come to him and the
lack of filter and the Precision of his
speech just allows him to just things
just fall out of him and there's always
this weird debate about creativity which
is it kind of comes in two forms one of
which is what you might call sheer inate
Genius and the other one is hyper
accelerated rationality MH which is just
in the same time that the other person
is getting from A to B you're already at
F yeah but I mean what interests me also
is if you look at political
movements given the fact that psychology
is often quite oblique the way to solve
a problem this is this is what really
really bothers me about politics at the
moment which is in fact it's what my
next book is about if I can give a
taster which is the question is do you
want to win arguments or do you want to
solve
problems because the mode of thinking
you adopt if you want to solve a
problem is much more open-minded much
less dogmatic okay it's much more
oblique and creative than the mode you
would adopt if you want to win an
argument and what we've done is we've
selected for our leadership for our
politicians in some cases for our
business people and we've educated for
and we've promoted for the ability to
win
arguments
okay and
actually winning an argument and solving
a problem are two completely different
skill sets I'd argue so there's what
always fascinates me about Andrew Schulz
is okay if Andrew Schulz said you know
5% of what he says on stage in a
corporate environment or at Yale okay
you know if if if you consider you know
Rob Rob Henderson's experience at Yale
okay you know they practically have the
place shut down for def fumigation okay
and yet contaminated zont and yet his
audiences are completely mixed in every
sense I mean if you want a really if you
want a really really diverse group of
people genuinely representative and
diverse and Andrew Schulz audience is
pretty much as good as it gets and he
solves the problem which is interesting
okay not by pretending say race or
gender don't exist okay but by
highlighting the distinctions and then
taking the piss out of them yeah okay
now from an oblique kind of creative
point of view you have to ask the
question is that actually a better way
of solving the problem
than for example the extreme dogmatism
of say the politically correct movement
I don't like using the word woke
particularly okay now you know is part
of the solution that you know in other
words do you actually make people
pretend not to notice ethnic differences
and as a consequence become incredibly
anxious in the presence of any of those
differences okay or do you actually
acknowledge them make light of them
because but both of them are trying to
tune down the seriousness
both of them try to say okay the one of
them Works yes precisely now here's a
question I want I want to do some
empirical testing on this okay you do
occasionally at comedy clubs you do
occasionally get a pissed guy who
heckles and everybody gets really angry
okay but do you get violence ever
outside comedy clubs outside well inside
or outside I once I've seen one video in
the last few years where a Heckler has
tried to start on a a comedian but
unbelievably rare it's unbelievably rare
given that you're pointing out people
and saying stuff about them or their
wife or their relationship or their
Chastity or whatever I mean I
recommended I couldn't make it to Andrew
Schulz at the Royal Albert Hall but I
recommended people went for the limited
visibility seats not only because they
were cheaper but because given his crowd
work the blast radius the brilliant
thing is I could hide behind a pillar
and it's very unlikely I'd be singled
out as like the whitest guy he'd ever
seen or whatever it might have been yeah
yeah yeah and so you know what what's
interesting is those comedy audiences
are really fascinating just in terms of
their demographic constituency it's
teaching people a sort of a degree of uh
intellectual humbleness uh being able to
cast off the the tension that you have
when watching something occur by
laughing so I've noticed this I'm
preparing for my first live tour which
is happening around the UK and Island in
a couple of weeks time and as a part of
this I did a ton of work in progress
shows and we could feel I could see in
the room and feel in the room tension
Rising as I'm talking about whatever the
thing is that I'm talking about this
section about confidence or this section
about regret or this section about
whatever and there was bits where you
needed a laugh almost kind of like how a
dog shakes its coat when it's wet and
once cast it off yeah yeah so here
here's an interesting analogy okay in
terms of being right versus solving the
problem okay now if you want to win
arguments or if you want to win the
respect of a pi group who hold a
particular set of political views what
tends to happen is you get into a virtue
spiral I think that's what it's called
in the book Purity spiral Purity thank
you Purity spiral you become
absolutist and then because conflict is
inherently interesting an argument is
inherently interesting so if we hear
outside some people having an amicable
conversation we won't even bother to get
up if we hear a fight starting to break
up or two people shouting at each other
we'll have our noses pressed to the
window to see what's happening and
journalists and newspapers and media
know this so they focus on those areas
where there is the greatest polarization
which means you're focusing on the part
of the problem which is most difficult
to solve so the example I give because
I'm going to move away from politics
because when you mention politics
everything suddenly drives people to
this polarization I I try I aspire to be
the most left-wing person on the out
right okay which is which is which is I
find the conversation of the outright
inherently interesting but I try not to
become part of it and I occasionally you
know I write for The Spectator but I I'm
I occasionally write about the virtues
of Henry George or the insights of KL
Marx just to shake the whole thing up
again bloody interesting guy marks by
the way okay right I mean the I think I
think the actual the um uh the the way I
put it is the diagnosis is fascinating
and the prescription is terrible correct
okay correct um
now okay they're the perfect Exemplar of
where this problem goes wrong and this
is very difficult if you work in
advertising marketing because quite
often you're not criticizing the
intentionality or the aspiration of the
person you're merely saying that the way
you're going about this isn't working
very well okay so yes uh you know nearly
all the aspirations of say the diversity
and inclusion movement are those which
we should all generally support and I
don't want to ever get into that kind of
weird you know weird thing where you
start getting angry about trigger
warnings because if you give it about 10
minutes thought you realize that trigger
warning although they're a bit funny and
it's a bit weird when Netflix says may
contain nicotine use okay which you know
never put anybody off going to the
cinemar in 1946 you know imagine if you
had to do that Casablanca warning
nicotine use it's a bit weird okay but
it's a great idea okay some people may
be deeply upset by certain forms of
content and you should at least give
them the opportunity to kind of opt out
or to avoid it I don't you know yeah
okay we we can debate what is triggering
but nonetheless it's broadly speaking an
intelligent principle I think now so the
example I'll choose won't be from
politics because politics automatically
leads people to become tribal and
therefore they have to take a side okay
and the example I think is perfect is
cycling Mikey do you cycling Mikey is a
YouTuber okay and he goes around he
stands at a place in London called
Gandalf corner and if he sees a car
ducking around the wrong side of a keep
left Island he just stands in front of
it and refuses to let them move takes a
photograph reports them to the police
he's he's um uh he's got guy Richie um I
think he got did he get guy Richie
banned because he photographed him using
a mobile phone while stationary waiting
for a set of traffic lights and he sends
his film footage to the police he puts
it up on YouTube okay
now I basically support what he's trying
to do okay because I think cycling
safety is incredibly important and these
people are doing bad things okay we've
all done it let's be honest okay we've
all used a mobile phone uh when driving
we've just been lucky enough to get away
with it and I wish I'd never done it
okay where cycl Mike is less effective
however is his mode of delivery which is
so combative and so effectively
polarizing okay that it actually becomes
counterproductive now where he you know
he he he's he's well intentioned which
is he wishes to increase cyclist safety
no no one's disagreeing with that okay
where he's less effective is in
disabusing People of The wellestablished
Stereotype that all africanas are
bastards um because he does things which
are inherently first of all he's a
little bit unfair because when he
catches when cyclists misbehave one you
can't report them to the police because
they don't have a license plate secondly
he claims that if you stand in front of
a cyclist or a motorcycle they might
fall off so he can't actually stop
motorcyclists and cyclists performing
egregious and illegal acts so he
concentrates entirely on the motorist
but then he B Seely goes stands in front
of them on the road and then effectively
does things which I mean we don't really
have a massive culture of vigilantism in
this country reporting other people to
the police is something we're pretty
reluctant to do you know it's not a
hellmark of a nice culture when people
are blagging you know basically you know
lagging to the screws as it used to be
called in prisoner of Cell Block H right
okay it's something you just don't do
but secondly I'm there as a marketing
guy going look I support what you're
trying to do but you've been driven into
this extreme position where your Purity
spiral is so extreme that actually it's
counterproductive yeah and so you you
know you're very very good at feeling
confident in your own opinions but
actually your ability to bring now if
you notice in advertising it's very rare
that you're nasty to users of your
competing product okay you don't get
Ford ads going if you drive a voxel
you're a [__] yes okay because genuinely
people want to win over people who
either undecided or in a rival camp and
it's not a good idea and you won't see
much advertising that does that to
patronize them or to effectively become
incredibly sanctimonious as he does I
mean extraordinarily
sanctimonious and I think it's I think
it's a kind of example of a pattern you
see where people's desire to be entirely
on the right drives them to practice
counterproductive behaviors because I
mean
uh there's you know for example I think
as a marketing guy I can't help watching
this go thing and say if you're actually
very nice to those people and you handed
them a leaflet which you produced
yourself you know just warning them of
cyclist safety I think it would probably
quite effective yeah I mean I was
actually I went on a speed awareness
course I don't know if you ever had that
I've had to do it once I had the
pleasure I turned up thinking this is
total ass but I'm doing it to avoid the
points it was pretty worthwhile in the
end at the end of it I went away going
okay I have rethought quite a bit of
driving pattern as a consequence of what
I learned it's reeducation now if you
turn so there's this huge problem okay
which is that everything now I think
Douglas Murray says this which I thought
was interesting it was actually had a
dinner which he said his the real reason
he gets angry about the culture wars
which I think is the right reason to be
angry about them is not because
somebody's wrong and somebody's right
and goodness says what it's the
extraordinary opportunity cost that
while we are arguing about these things
that are very difficult to decide and
which automatically polarize people
there are 100 problems we we could solve
okay which would actually appeal to
everybody yeah as he says while The
Barbarians are at the gates we'll be
debating about what gender they are well
this is an interesting one because I'd
also argue let's take cyclists and
motorists okay every it's in everybody's
interest to effectively Foster hostility
between these two groups even though of
course quite a lot of people straddle
both groups outside London it's quite
rare to be a cyclist who doesn't also
own a car okay not not not totally rare
but most people outside Lon most
households have access to a car in some
shape or
form and Mar there is that imagine what
you could have done if instead of
fostering cyclist motorist hostility by
focusing on the areas where uh there's
the most Discord and the most
disagreement imagine if you both said
okay there two things that mo one thing
that motorists hate and cyclists hate
even more potholes right now bind them
together bind them together and say look
potholes are really annoying to car
owners cuz you got to get your tires
replaced which by the way is
environmentally bad as well [__]
moral Terror to a total Terror to a
cyclist particularly if you're on one of
those narrow tired you know titanium
rich thingy Mobs with yra and everything
else and um so it's it's kind of
interesting which is the point is that
the opportunity cost of this focus on
problems that divide you know problems
where the solution acutely divides
people is has a huge cre opportunity
cost because the thing to do if you have
two people who disagree about something
is to change the question okay obviously
we're not getting anywhere here so let's
just solve something else there's a
there's a quote from Scott Alexander
which is really great it says if you're
interested in being on the right side of
disputes you will refute your opponent's
arguments but if you're interested in
producing truth you will fix your
opponent's Arguments for them to win you
must fight not only the creature you
encounter you must fight the most horri
horrible thing that can be constructed
from its corpse well well let me I'll
I'll I'll come back to you with a quote
which is Thomas Soul um as I said I'm
the most left-wing person on the alt
right I'm I'm I'm a very big admirer of
of quite a lot of the people Soul
included Thomas Soul's phenomenal
absolutely phenomenal guy activism is a
way for useless people to feel important
even if the consequences of their
activism are counterproductive for those
they claim to be helping and damaging to
the fabric of society as a whole okay
now one of the weirdest things about
this movement okay and one of the most
tiring things about being politically
correct as a Brit is weirdly you have to
pretend you're
American because okay if you think about
it okay there are loads of problems you
can solve at the local level this place
here okay sort out the [__] signage
right I first of all you come into a
place to find it and it's like the St
Valentine's Day Massacre you know you
come into this weird news okay where the
only thing you can imagine happening
there you know it looks as if you know
the interior Decor has been done by Pete
docky right and then you you got the
signage and the numbering is completely
batshit insane and you can only read the
the actual number of each door if the
Sun is at a particular angle okay so
there all these things we can do to
solve problems locally at a smaller
level but if you want to feel
self-important you concentrate on the
problems at the top you know things like
effectively politics I mean if you look
at actually even things at the level of
kind of um probably not London actually
but if you look at I don't know why do
we never get any coverage of say the
mayor of Manchester or the mayor of the
West Midlands we got a lot of coverage
of Scottish politics right okay because
why because there's a massive divisive
issue there which gets people worked up
which is Scottish
independence where by the way we're
asking the wrong question anyway the
question should be what kind of
Independence do we want not do we have
Independence or don't we completely
lacking in Nuance anyway okay you never
get any coverage no coverage now bear in
mind the population of Scotland is
smaller than the population of Yorkshire
okay most people don't realize that they
I think because it's kind of large
geographic area there are about 15 or 20
million people living in Scot abandoned
it's it's very small population because
all the really talented ones moved to
Wales in the 19th century um sorry
that's just my that's just my own
ancestry sorry you know in in search of
people who weren't permanently angry
about nothing in particular and so my
great-grandfather moved from K N to the
South Welsh valys because it was kind of
In fairness Cardiff was like the Dubai
of the of late 19th century Cardiff was
of the late 19th first place in the
world where a million pound contract was
signed was in cardi docs it was coal so
it was effectively the largest coal
exporting port in the world wow and by
the way not your shitty German coal
proper quality coal right here's a
question sorry here's a question for you
why is it that when we look at the uh
export of national identities from the
UK and Ireland to the rest of the world
uh England English people we have a a I
although we get referred to as being
British y uh Northern Irish people kind
of do Southern Irish people absolutely
definitely do even Scottish people do oh
Scottish marketing is brilliant I mean
as as as a nation brand it's absolutely
potent as hell yeah why does no one what
what's happened to Wales why has Wales
not managed to establish itself on the
global geopolitical branding there's an
interesting debate about this one one
Welsh commentator I'm not don't shoot
the messenger here suggests that Welsh
people who move somewhere else very
rapidly kind of lose their welness and
assimilate anywhere that's his argument
so if you look at the contribution of
Welsh Americans okay now you've never
heard you've never heard that hyphen
before have you okay Irish American
Scottish American yeah absolutely you've
never heard of Welsh American includes
like Thomas Jefferson okay it includes
arguably Elvis about 50% of country
singers Tammy winnette real surname Pew
okay right if you actually Hillary
Clinton funnily enough um is I think
half Welsh okay so you have this but but
there is AB I mean if if you ask people
who are American about their Welsh
ancestry they may dimly know uh that
they have some Welsh ancestry it barely
extends to knowing where it is whereas
if they got Scottish or Irish ancestry
it informs every [__] cell of their
being even if they're like a 16th Irish
they start wearing green things yeah and
you know um to the slight annoyance by
the way of real Irish people I might add
okay to be honest okay and quite a few
people who are very proud of their Irish
heritage are actually descended from
northern Irish Protestants what's
sometimes called in the United States
Scots Irish but they don't even know
that okay so you know I think Henry Ford
there's a huge Irish American contingent
of people who are effectively um uh from
Northern Ireland um but again
that distinction isn't really
made uh there is an argument that it was
at the time of the American Civil War
where people tended to take sides on
that basis I'm not quite sure um but
generally that doesn't that hasn't
pervaded until the you know 2023 but the
Welsh have done a bad job there's
actually a group called Global Welsh
which I belong to which looks at this
question of kind of I mean the greatest
Welsh American by the way was a guy
called Russell cavl Humphries who was
number two to alapo okay I'm not making
this up okay so this guy who was um by
the way he was known by the by the
various feds and people out for him as
the nicest man in the mob okay and big
Welsh from I think he was from Carno
which is in kind of the middle you know
kind of mid whal tiny little bit his
parents were okay and he was entirely
Welsh and uh read sorry M did I say
Russell Murray Murray the camel
Humphries and um or Murray the hump he
was known as which is either to do with
humph or to do with the fact that he
wore a camel coat but I think I think um
he um effectively he he he would
occasionally kill people but he'd only
negot he'd always negotiate first and I
think one of the senior feds who are
supposed to arrest him uh actually
refused to turn up to arrest him because
he liked him personally okay and didn't
want to be part of the arrest and he was
also uh violently against curing by the
way okay of a massive organized crime
killer but kill not a swearer no no he
didn't didn't like any of that any of
that but research him because it's
really really it's comically funny the
idea of a Welsh guy in the mob I looked
at a study recently that showed an
inverse correlation between marriage
length and cost of engagement ring and
wedding combined that the more that is
spent on the engagement ring and the
more that is spent on almost in pure
economic terms you'd expect it to be the
other way around because the sunk cost
of wedding should skin in the game
should ensure the duration of the
wedding equally what are you trying to
prove yes yes okay yeah what what have
you learned you must have some insights
about engagement rings and their
Heritage and their history I mean what
is what is interesting is that um uh
there is a degree where what you're
practicing there is a form of commitment
device in other words it's an
unrecoverable sunk cost which is upfront
expense being proof of long-term
commitment and I've made that point that
some advertising works that way okay
in other words you wouldn't spend a
fortune advertising this car if it were
a waste of time for me to test drive it
okay so once you spent the money on
Advertising it's gone therefore the only
possible value of the of advertising is
that it leads to a sale therefore if you
are advertising a new product heavily
you are confident rightly or wrongly but
it doesn't matter you yourself who know
the product better than the buyer does
is confident in terms of its long-term
appeal and um desirability when test
driven and so you know some part of
advertising undoubtedly Works through
sheer costly expenditure she costly
signaling wasn't you you guys did a
study where heavyweight paper was the
most effective thing to increase Charity
donations uh that's right yes now you
will never ever get any what's so
interesting about some of this research
is it uncovers things which people feel
but don't even think or say so there's
this quote probably wrongly attributed
to David Ogie that he said the trouble
with market research is people don't
think what they feel they don't say what
they think and they don't do what they
say now no everybody would say that a
charity donation uh should be sent out
on the cheapest paper possible because
you should minimize your marketing cost
what we found is that when you put
slightly more expensive paper in the
donation envelope was for Christian Aid
week actually uh slightly more people
give but people give much more large
donations so the volume of donations
over 50 or100 was significantly
increased now that's unconscious it's
probably you know if this thing's flimsy
and there may be a certain degree of
reciprocation in that which is they've
sent me a bit of nice bit of paper I owe
them 50 Quid I mean there you know we
how it works by the way why it works you
could come up with four or five
different possible explanations but um
those kind of things are really
fascinating because they are they belong
to that field of activity which you can
only prove through testing market
research won't tell you the answer pure
Theory won't tell you the answer you
have to test I'm not a very prejudiced
man but given my background as a
nightlife club promoter uh living and
breathing flyers and paper for a very
long time did you do that nightclub game
where you created artificially long cues
of course I did course you did of course
I did let me let me let me give you this
one first so one of the few prejudices
that I have in my life is against
single-sided Flyers single-sided Flyers
are around about 90% is expensive to do
double-sided Flyers because almost all
Flyers are double-sided my second
biggest pre this are against
double-sided flies with the same thing
printed on both sides you have two sides
of a piece of paper that basically says
I can't even be bothered here what
should we put on the back I just put the
same thing command C command V send it I
don't care then after that just tiny
tiny little things that you can do we
found that if you go there's something
called um uh spot UV which is the kind
of gloss that you put over the top of a
piece of paper that gives it a smooth
finish if you go uncoated which isn't
that much more again and if you go a
little bit heavier GSM you get this
almost sort of organic furry feel to it
it's like every um innocent smoothie
label right you know it kind of feels a
bit more kind of raw and organic and and
and natural we see what we're talking
about here is This brilliant thing okay
which is it's very simple if you want to
solve problems okay which is stop trying
to think like Newton and come up with
universal universally applicable context
free laws okay that's been done okay
it's called physics okay we've done that
instead you got to think like Darwin
okay
now we mentioned earlier this this
difference between effectively
evolutionary thinking which I think um
the evolution is a study of how things
change not how things are okay that's a
fundamental difference what do you mean
well Evolution come the most benale
description of evolution but which is
also incredibly insightful is things are
the way they are because they got that
way okay which sounds like AB absurdity
but when you when you actually think a
little bit deeply then it forces you to
ask the question well how do they get
that way okay and where else could we go
from here you know what are the tools
that are disposable to to get from here
to somewhere better okay now one of the
things I think that is an obstacle to
problem solving I think the reason that
comedians are often evolutionary
thinkers Ricky jaase being an obvious
case but John C another one okay
absolutely fascinated by um you know
evolutionary thought is because it's a
gate it's it's a gateway to complexity
it's a gateway to thinking in terms of
complex systems and complex systems
changing over time and and it's an
Escape From the idea that there must be
universal laws I've got a friend called
Jag Balor known on the web as hanging
noodles who always argues that we
monotheistic cultures like Christianity
have a disadvantage in our thinking
because unlike Hindus um we're prone to
what he calls mono theism we need one
Theory to explain everything okay and he
points out that actually in ISM you you
know we don't have that problem because
we're used to the fact that there's you
know the elephant and the I me I think I
think he said his mother praised on an
altar which has an elephant a monkey and
Jesus on it right and there's no there's
no inherent contradiction to that now
actually that's why I'm quite hopeful
about having a Hindu prime minister
because I think if we unleashed his uh
lack of monotheism and freed him from
political Dogma uh he could be
creatively really quite interesting but
that complexity thing is really
interesting because one of the things
that you you need to lose in order to
understand complex systems is an idea of
what you might call discussing things
that make you look important one person
call it the higher twad and that's to
that's you know I noticed this with a
former Chief Executive you know if he
was interviewed instead of talking about
advertising and you know he'd always
talk about like the fed and Janet Yellen
you know and likely interest rate Rises
okay right and that's kind of an that's
a self-important thing to talk about
weirdly people in Britain instead of
solving British problems somehow weirdly
adopt American it's a signaling thing
and it's a signaling thing which is I
care about these things at and I'm I'm
so important that I'm only going to
debate them at the very highest level
okay and so I mean there are all these
people people going around to to defund
the police in the United States I'm
going I'm a Brit right first of all my
responsibility for what I think is a
terrible criminal justice system in the
United States my responsibility for that
ended in 1776 okay I don't think I think
it's great but it's not my problem okay
secondly I wanted to start some Brits
demonstrations going around going disarm
the
police because it's it's what's so
interesting is if you're American this
defund the police is debatable but the
idea that the police shouldn't carry
guns is probably to them so bizarre that
they think you're insane okay other
things in the United States four weeks
of paid vacation okay I've never met
anybody in Britain so right-wing that
they think we should have less holiday
time nobody zero nobody's ever said we
another 2% on GDP growth if we just got
rid of people's holiday doesn't happen
never exists okay if we cut maternity
leave down two ands no no no those
things actually once you have them
they're air fryers they're Japanese
toilets once you have them there's no
going back everyone's an evangelist
grandfa once you once once once you've
got there you never go back yeah okay
and I'm kind of going well look you know
first of all you you have to now if you
look at what Darwin did to have what is
probably one of the five big biggest
insights to be honest I mean I'm going
to stand up for Alfred Russell Wallace
not least because I was born in lumad
which is the same Village that he was
born in tiny Welsh village um and my my
ambition is to be I think you probably
already succeeded is the the second best
evolutionary thinker born in ladic I
think that's a kind of attainable
sensible ambition okay um but uh I'm
really worried that someone will crop up
you know you know Imperial College
London of fledging evolutionary
psychologist from lum exactly Christ
yeah and um so was really sweet because
I spoke at the Royal Institution and I
made the prediction that I was probably
only the second person from lmad ever to
have spoken at the Royal Institution and
sure enough I think Alfred Russell
Wallace spoke there in sort of 1860
whatever it was he survived into the
20th century actually um but but if you
look at what Darwin did and what Russell
Wallace did okay they didn't get they
didn't get involved in self-aggrandizing
theory first they went around
interesting funny little places and they
looked at the beaks of fines okay now I
think if you want to solve political
problems actually this is why I love
working in advertising okay because you
can get down into the weeds of
microscopic things like what's the
effect of choice architecture on
property selection or indeed dating
websites you can actually we have a kind
of Mantra in our Behavioral Science
practice which is dare to be trivial
because our argument is in a complex
system quite often the things that make
a difference may be surprisingly small
they're kind of Butterfly Effects and
your job is to look for the point of
intervention in the system where the
smallest change has the biggest effect
Buck Mr Fuller called it trim tab okay
on his gravestone it says call me trim
tab and the trim tab I don't I'm I'm not
an engineer but it's the bit on the end
of a Rudder I think on a ship or
plane which only moves slightly but it's
the greatest point of Leverage in terms
of turning that ship it's like an extra
Rudder on the end of a Rudder or
something yeah yeah yeah and my point is
that we have and I had an argument with
someone who was the I think he was the
political correspondent of the ft and I
said when John Major you a lot of your
listeners be too young to remember this
but um uh I'm always conscious of this I
I found myself doing things like now
explaining what a fax machine was and
things like that but when he invented
the cones hotline he was widely
ridiculed for that okay so he invented
this thing which was a a phone number
where you could report cones that were
block off the road where no Road Works
were being performed and you could also
say you know you could also get advanced
warning of where Cones were going to be
now at the time he came up with that he
was the Prime Minister okay and this was
regarded as the most comical and absurd
thing you could possibly imagine like
everyone was being tyrannized by roving
bands of cones he was solving a problem
which you like poels which annoys a
great number of people all the time okay
and it was non-controversial
but it was considered absolutely beneath
his dignity well my only argument is
that probably the way you solve big
problems is by tinkering around with a
lot of small things and then sometimes
the big problems just weirdly go away
okay I think that tackling problems head
on is usually counterproductive but the
argumentation tendency that people want
to win an argument rather than solving a
problem first of all causes this tribal
polarization which means that people
very rapidly then start saying I won't
actually argue for what's good I'll
argue for whatever path of action most
annoys my opposing tribe correct yeah
it's it's not what's most effective it's
what signals that I am a acolyte yes I'm
a devoted unquestioning aaly of this
particular let me give you this I've
come up with this idea of the unreliable
Ally so if I know one of your views and
from it I can accurately predict
everything else that you believe you're
probably not a serious thinker because
you've put your entire world ideology on
as a onesie inly Dominic cummings's
great Insight was he said that
effectively the language of left or
right is a is a tribal convenience for
people who are into Political cosplay
okay correct it's it's rather like you
know okay most people are kind of
interested in politics in the way that
I'm interested in Star Wars which is
I'll watch it if it happens to be on but
I'm not going to go to a convention and
dress as Darth Vader okay and politics
is full of the kind of people who dress
up as Darth Vader you know get
unbelievably involved in insane details
of you know how the Federation is
actually the governance of the
Federation or something okay most people
aren't like that the other Insight of
dominant Cummings was he said most
people in reality are both more
left-wing and more right-wing than
politicians fully understand so Ordinary
People in a way are saner and more
diverse politically than the people
who've been forced to take sides yeah
they get reduced down to a dashboard
though right and that isn't able to
fully capture you know one vote from
somebody doesn't fully encapsulate just
how far right and how far left you are
because on balance you aggregated that
you are a bit left so you voted labor
you are a bit right so you voted
conservative this idea so avoiding that
identitarian thing I mean you know I I I
I write for The Spectator part because
the weird thing is it would have been
complet actually no that's not fair okay
actually that's not fair I was going to
say that in the 1970s it would have been
the opposite where the right-wing press
got much more annoyed about you writing
something left-wing than vice versa
actually that's probably not fair of the
British very interesting by the way
which is if you're American okay there's
quite a simple narrative which you can
reasonably believe which is that most
progress socially not necessarily
economically but most social progress
happens under a democratic regime okay
so you go back to say wh votes for women
that was my cousin woodro who is De
bizarrely he's like my fourth cousin
twice R his mom was English from a
Scottish family okay um uh I I Ju Just
just to even things out my my other
traced American relative is in prison in
Washington state for kidnapping and
attempted murder so swings the
roundabouts right yeah um but um uh the
the interesting thing there is that you
know most of those kind of uh forward
movements the Civil Rights Movement Etc
happened under in a democratic regime
okay and so it's very easy if you take
the American narrative on board which is
basically they're these well-intentioned
Democrat people who do nice things and
then Republicans tend to be nasty okay I
don't think that Maps very neatly onto
the UK okay so if you look at the UK uh
votes for women was actually a
conservative government uh the NHS was
set up undoubtedly by labor government
atly but actually on the recommendations
of Beverage who is a liberal okay um I
think um same-sex marriage was
conservative government I think the
legalization of by the way if you go
back the Guardians supported the south
in the American Civil War okay The
Spectator right with publication was
about the only publication in the UK to
support the uh Union against the
Confederacy The Spectator in the
1960s okay was known as the buggers
bugle for its campaigning for the
legalization of homosexuality okay and
another force that was absolutely
decisive in that campaign was bizarrely
the Church of England so there's well
not that bizarrely I suppose if you
consider homosexuals in CIA Church
Physicians perhaps okay no no no no no
at the time no there were quite a few
trust me okay but but I mean actually
there was an Archbishop of Canterbury at
some point in the 60s who kind of needed
protection because of his position on
that matter if you want to if you want
to see a really Advanced group in terms
of being ahead of the curve on anything
it's the Quakers I mean if you're an
empiricist everybody would become a you
know what we really need is a Quaker
Revival okay but the thing is you can't
have a demonstration can you as a quake
you what do we want sh okay it doesn't
really work but but my point is that
actually if you look at it if you look
at the British social
progress I mean you know the
anti-slavery campaign as some of them
were Tory okay schury was it's actually
British progress is much much less easy
to uh kind of stereotype than in the
United
States and so you know you actually look
at the you know you look at the history
of different Publications and their
opinions on different things the idea
actually which my kids seemed to absorb
which was everything was horrible until
left-wing people came along and made it
better yeah more this s of this force of
History thing is kind of a bit borne out
I have to say in the U you know it's
complicated obviously it's a bit you
know you could say well there is some
empirical evidence for that in the
United States although you had a
Democratic party which was completely
weird for you know while the South was
overwhelmingly Democrat you had that
kind of weird Unholy Alliance thing
going on but it's not really safe and
this business of taking American
concerns because they're the most
important because it's America okay and
getting wildly excited about them in the
UK even though our problems are
different okay so I'll give you just a
very simple example of this which is you
know if you talk about white privilege
okay and I I'm to some extent the
beneficiary inarguably of exactly that
but the only point I'd make is that when
I was one of the reasons I'm white okay
apart from the obvious ones one of the
reasons I'm right is I was born in the
UK in
1965 when I think someone will correct
me on this the population of the UK was
97% white okay in
1965 so you know the odds that I'm going
to be white it's not like it's not it's
not a situation like the United States
where you've had generations of people
effectively unfairly disadvantaged okay
the people who are disadvantaged hadn't
arrived at the point when I was being
born to the to the most part
okay now as a consequence simply try
transplanting uh American history and
American preoccupations and American
narratives and imposing them on
Australia the UK France okay doesn't
really work and yet these people do it
because they want to identify themselves
with the highest profile um uh you know
biggest debates doour so they can take
sides and that's completely inimical to
you know we got we got other things to
be guilty of if we're Brits let's be
honest okay it's very interesting
actually I I had a great aunt who's an
anthropologist called beatric
Blackwood who spent her her life kind of
connected to the pit Rivers Museum and
her diary survive and sometime in about
1923 she went to Memphis I think might
have been I think it was Memphis okay I
thought that be interesting to see you
know how how does you know fairly you
know obviously she an anthropologist
fairly conventional English woman of
1923 upper middle class family how does
she react to going to the American South
in the 1920s and I thought her action
gosh this is really you know tiny bit
you know this is a bit dodgy you know
it's a bit off you know she was abely
horrified I mean there's there's just
these pages of her raging against the
fact that she wasn't even allowed to
visit a black household because they
wouldn't allow her in because if word
got out that a white woman had been in
their house there'd be trouble okay
now yeah we got we got loads of flaws
over here which we can solve and we can
look at but I don't think there's a
wonderful case from your part of the
world isn't there which is a battle
where the pubs refused to deny access to
colored servicemen when when they were
bed somewhere in the Northeast isn't it
not sure are you a monkey hanger are you
or technically a smoggy oh you're a
smoggy as it's referred to the American
audience at this point just
completely got it it where ICI a huge
big industrial plant that spews out all
manner of smokers but I mean you know
different countries you know the
situation in Canada is fundamentally
different from the situation elsewhere
where and the idea that you have to
solve problems by basically looking to
the United States and then just
importing wholesale whatever happens to
be the fashionable topic dujour over
there seems to me crazy and if I were in
the US I'd be competing anyway for four
weeks paid vacation which would benefit
everybody yeah that seems to be the F
the Vanguard of social change should be
paid vacation and a bit more maternity
leave the only person who suggested that
was Bernie Saunders and everybody
thought he was some sort of communist
well I'm not sure if it was just because
of that that they thought he was a
communist but there may be other reasons
as well one of my favorite stories that
I've learned over the last couple of
years about David ogy that I've never
got a chance to talk to you about was
when Fortune published an article and
titled it is David Ogie a genius
question mark I asked my lawyer to sue
the editor for the question
mark um is there any truth in that
gosh funny enough he's an interesting
case in point because he's a university
dropout okay so he didn't have a degree
he was when he started the agency he was
former Chef failed tobacco farmer I
think during the war he'd been in MI6
somewhere in Washington as well he was
kind of Ian Fleming character in many
way actually um you know he he Ian
Fleming by the way was also successful
in a sense relatively late in life um
and by the way we need more of these
stories because you know you can re you
know it's never too late Colonel Sanders
you know sorry was 65 when he founded
Kentucky Fried Chicken as then was okay
um and David OG was a kind of Colonel
Sanders of advertising he was relatively
late he had the advantage of surviving
for a long time there are people within
Ogie who think that his brother Francis
who tragically died young and was based
in the UK rather than the US was as much
the brains behind the operation as David
was but I I met him once fortunately and
I knew his wife quite well his widow now
um
and
yeah I think he had some advantages okay
so he was doing advertising at first for
Fairly aspirational products at a time
of Great American angila so he was
advertising Guinness Rolls-Royce um
scheps um the English tourist board for
example which allowed him to do a
particular style of kind of Urbane
aspirational advertising at a time when
most American advertising was quite
crash crash yeah it was to an educated
audience that could work out the I mean
famously that Rolls-Royce advertisement
at 60 MPH appeared only twice and it was
in the Wall Street Journal I think what
was that at 60 mil now the loudest sound
in this new Rolls-Royce is the ticking
of the electric clock what is it that
makes the Rolls-Royce the best car in
the world there really is no magic about
it it is simply patient attention to
detail says an eminent Rolls-Royce
engineer I even memorized the subhead
but it's um he was very um the one thing
everybody can learn from him is uh
writing and he is closest I think as a
Pros writer if you read his books one of
his books is terrible weirdly which I
think it's called blood brains and
beards as autobiography the rest of the
books are excellent um I think
everybody's allowed one bad book uh but
um uh it's a wonderful proos style very
similar to Conan doy in that it's very
very simple and easy to read with every
sort of 57th word being a slightly more
complicated or slightly more High futin
word just to remind the reader that
writer isn't an idiot yeah and I think
it's it's actually a great approach to
communication which is that little
signaling of in the Rolls-Royce
advertisement if you are too diffident
to drive a Rolls-Royce you can drive a
Bentley yeah she says you have a Bentley
with a less kind of grandiose radiator
Grill
effectively and you know and so he was
it was actually it's a probably actually
you know other people who are big fans
of that kind of pro Kingsley Amis was a
big admirer of Conan doy and it's a
particular way of writing which is
incredibly easy to read but at the same
time really intelligent and quite Urbane
what I really what I really loved about
at least my research that I have managed
to do with David Ogie is uh his approach
to engendering which you guys have
obviously continued now uh engendering
this there are no wrong answers
creativity kind of culture which I think
is really great well it's a huge I mean
I was saying to some clients the other
day we actually we make it easy for
ourselves in one way which is it's one
of very few corporate set this is why
I'm very interested in the comedy world
I'm very interested in other forms of
anomalous economic activity if you like
where you're actually paid to be
weird and you you don't realize how rare
and precious it is until you move into
until you encounter management
Consultants okay where the whole thing
is kind of templated formulaic they
recruit engineering graduates which by
the way is a terrible waste of
engineering talent I want Engineers
going and making bloody things I don't
want them bloody well producing
PowerPoint decks at sort of200 pound an
hour what a waste you know you know
those people could be producing I don't
know space Rockets or something but
instead they're going and producing
these effing PowerPoint decks for
management consulting firms and the the
value of actually having so most
organizations first of all regard logic
as a good proxy for um in other words
the course of action that has the best
argument attached must be the best
course of action
and what's unusual about advertising and
comedy and a few other things music
obviously I guess um is that we don't
buy that that we don't buy the idea that
whatever has a good argument attached to
it must be right because there's
probably a better idea which comes from
Left Field which you won't arrive at
through pre- rationalization you can
only post-rational eyesee it now that
distinction by the way is quite
interesting um I won't go into the whole
thing about Charles Russ purse brilliant
American philosopher of the 19th century
and um I won't go into the stuff about
um you know the whole thing of abductive
inference being a different form of
mental process but if you look at
actually quite a lot of pharmaceutical
progress okay it actually happens
backwards okay it's not we have this
disease we need to cure it oh look let's
do these things here's a cure those
processes generally lead to fairly well
actually not that reliable you know
tolerable incremental progress over a
very long period now let's not discount
that because over a period of 80 years
we do get better at
things the real breakthrough things
happen backwards okay which is Viagra
penicillin yeah in other words um it's
almost a cure for which there is no
known disease rather than a disease for
which there's no what can we use this
for it's giving people erections uh well
what happened was it was intended as an
angina remedy Viagra and there are two
stories about about it one of which is
that the nurses noticed that when the
guys came in for their kind of people on
the trial when they came in for their
kind of checkup they were sitting in a
really weird way okay and the other the
other story I've heard is that at the
end of the trial they were told well
okay um we we're obviously processing
the trial results which were pretty
inconclusive as far as angina went so
could you hand back any unused pills you
have to which the response in every
previous trial had been yeah sure here
they are and in this trial went
no
there's also a fascinating story which
is that a German pharmaceutical company
got there first noticed the side effect
and immediately rejected the drug okay
because they failed to see the
opportunity to in other words as an an
any angina cure that caused people to go
around in a priapic state of tence was
obviously no good as an angina
medication and they failed to see beyond
it which is that now I'll tell you two
other stories of this I was talking to
some other people one of the great
things about being a Vice chairman you
can just go and talk to I mean to be
honest okay most discussion and
decision-making argumentation is top
down most progress is bottom up or
horizontal okay so we organize
organizations in the absolute worst way
for problem solving which is what you
know what you need is people who know
quite a bit about three different things
to solve a problem because more and more
Modern Problems aren't problems within a
specialism they're problems that involve
the combination of two specialisms so
anyway here's an interesting one which
is a drugs company I was speaking to
giving a talk to and to be honest I
think I learn as when I give these talks
companies often I learn as much from
them as they do from me but they pay me
so fine okay um this is a case where
they were looking at drugs to treat um
autoimmune diseases such as rheumatoid
arthritis and what happened was that
some of the drugs they tested were
appalling right because they actually
had the opposite effect they boost to
the immune system and of course if
you've got a disease where your immune
system is attacking your own body it's
the worst thing you want to do so they
put these on the shelf and go okay you
know rule that out and then someone a
little while later goes
ding if you're trying to practice
immunotherapy for cancer a drug that
strengthens the immune system that's not
a bug that's a feature okay and
similarly that happened with Night Nurse
which is one of my favorite marketing
stories where they were looking when
they created nurse and this was long
before there was something called day
nurse okay they were looking to produce
a a flu remedy and they produced a very
successful to be honest it was treating
actually of treating the symptoms rather
than the cause okay but they produced
this flu treatment so not a remedy but a
treatment uh which was brilliant but the
downside was it sent you to sleep so you
couldn't drive or operate heavy
machinery um don't regularly operate
heavy machinery but it's a bit I love
that warning yeah I love that warning
too yeah oh [__] I was about to do some
heavy Excavating
driving has been taken completely it's
rather like that video message which is
you mustn't show this video on an oil
rig do you remember that in the
beginning of VHS videos it said this is
not licensed for the display on oil rigs
and you imagine those people 500 miles
out of the North Sea going oh [__] press
the pause we're about to watch speed two
we just about to watch speed two and
that's ruined it for us you know any
moment now someone's going to turn up
from the copyright licensing Authority
and BP are going to be in trouble
and um but anyway um the the fascinating
thing is that what happened is they said
okay so it's no good it sends people to
sleep and then a little guy I've always
heard the story as a little guy kind of
from the marketing department said
actually if you position it as a
nighttime flu remedy okay the fact that
it sends you to sleep is a bonus it's
not a problem so night nurse was born by
basically reframing and this is what I
said about highs speeded 2 I said High
spe 2 is a terrible answer really um in
the sense that it goes at the wrong
speed along the wrong route um lots of
things are terrible about you the whole
thing was misconceived but it was the
first thing that was wrong about high
spe 2 was the question they asked and
they asked an engineering question which
is how do you transport X people over y
miles uh you know at a time of Zed T
okay right and so they set down those
kind of mathematical parameters now a
marketing person would have asked a
different question which is a much more
interesting open-ended question which
has far more scope for expanding the
solution space to allow for Creative
Solutions and the question a marketer
would have asked is how do you make the
train service between Manchester and
London so good and so enjoyable people
feel stupid
driving now speed obviously okay speed
may be part of that convenience Comfort
enjoyability connectivity catering okay
um variation of seating so you know I
mean you remember strangers on a train
there Hitchcock films where they used to
have the observation car at the back of
the train [__] me every time you watch
this is a train in the 1950s you go oh
God I wish they had trains like that now
they even had a smoking thing at the
back didn't they now I did have a crazy
idea which is if you spent the money
okay this is hypothetical but this is
why comedy is so important it's much
more easy to start silly and R it back
than it is to start boring and rain it
forwards as it were and I said just a
hypothetical exercise if you spent if
you kept the tracks the same and you
spent all the money on both buying and
recreating the world's greatest steam
locomotives right and you ran the trains
from Manchester like your train at 9:15
will be pulled by the Union Pacific Big
Boy okay or the malard right or a
replica of the malard now it would be
slower okay I'm assuming the Wi-Fi could
be quite good you wouldn't go into full
you know kind of you know 19th century
or you know mid 20th century Nostalgia
but every single tourist to London would
go to Manchester just to ride on the
effing train right if you had a replica
of the bloody um Harry Potter train okay
you'd actually get people coming to
London so they could travel to
Manchester yeah if you think that's by
the way comical I've got a friend who's
the warden of an Oxford College uh a
former boss of mine um and the tourist
visitors to Oxford colleges basically
have completely bated there are colleges
which nobody visits and there are
colleges which are swarming with
tourists the entire discriminator
between those two is whether the college
features in a Harry Potter film wow so
new College Oxford has a tree apparently
which is featured in one of the films
and that has tourists swarming in next
door you can have a fantastic College
architecturally magnificent didn't
featur in Harry Potter you know
basically it's um pointless it's you
know it's what do you call those things
that blow through the place tumble weed
tumble weed yeah yeah what's your
thoughts on the abandonment of this
billion dollar train thing there
something recently that's been thrown
you can still solve it you go and hand
the job to I've said this you go and
hand1 million pound to Johnny Ives I and
his mate Mark new Mark new Australian
designer already has form here because
he designed the Quantas business class
seat which in my opinion is the best
actually never mind business class it's
the best airline seat ever conceived by
the wit of
man um and you say you give them the
brief okay we've got this stupid Railway
going along this stupid route how do you
make it just absolutely amazing I mean
Johnny Ives back in the UK right I'm
sure 100 million are get him out of bed
okay and you just go okay you're in
charge of the design of the train
Interiors you're in charge of the
catering the connectivity you're brief
open brief make this journey so amazing
that people want to go on the train for
the sake of the train not for the sake
of the journey that's the brief it's the
brief that Cunard effectively had okay
so when jet gen aircraft were invented
okay um the blue ribboned which was that
competition for how fast you could cross
the Atlantic became to be honest a bit
of an academic exercise because if you
could get there in under a day by plane
even if you had to refuel in Gander it
didn't really matter whether the QE the
Queen Mary was faster than the bloody
United States or the Normandy anymore
okay so kunard basically had to go okay
we've got to stop thinking of these
ships as a source of a form of
transportation they got to be a
destination in themselves and
consequently they kind of invented the
cruise ship industry sort off I I I
didn't give them 100% credit but that
idea of so cruise ships when you think
about it you board a cruise ship you go
around in a circle and you come back I
mean you do visits and plac for a
journey yeah yeah you know but actually
the cruise ship is as much of a
destination as the destination is and
you can do that with highspeed too yeah
what would you do train twister is my
suggestion solution to train
overcrowding is to turn close proximity
to other people from an annoyance to a
source of entertainment okay a lot of
intimacy concerns there yeah they
probably I did think of the legalities
but you know your next station is corn
left hand
yellow come on come
on you You' probably have to have gender
segreg Tes that's a concern it depends
if you're going to Brighton or not that
might be a bonus um you've also got the
the issue I suppose I've seen a lot of
the people that travel up and down this
country is getting older yeah and I'm
not sure whether you'd have to have at
each different stop some sort of
paramedic perhaps or or a physio that
could get R by the way that is part of
the appeal of the cruise ship industry
to the elderly in the United States
which is you got a doctor on board right
you've got three weeks where your
medical care is basically taken care of
if you tumble tumble down the water
slide too quickly not irrelevant and by
the way if you're a cruise ship doctor
you're a [__] good doctor because
you got to be able to cope with
everything right you can't specialize if
someone's on board and you're sort of
you know 200 miles from Land you can't
say I'm terribly sorry it's not my
specialism I need perforated eardrum to
a half exact exactly yeah I bet you got
to be a [__] hot generalist What would
do to improve business class flights
interesting uh yeah I've got an idea for
that for short Hall which is really
mischievous you know how they always say
that the the biggest car company in the
world Uber doesn't own any cars and the
biggest uh you know accommodation
company in the world Airbnb doesn't own
any houses I've got this idea to start
an airline that doesn't own any planes
okay and this is I did think of having a
vaping Airline I did wonder about that
or you could just Vape on board you just
Vape on board s that you know like a
vaping tax vaping search charge yeah and
and you'd have two you know you'd have
two classes you know 20 milligrams at
the front 10 Mig at the back fantastic
but I didn't wonder about that but
actually my idea was you buy a country
house near stanstead okay and every time
you fly okay you park your car at this
country house okay you're check in your
luggage and the country house is is like
the party in The Wolf of Wall Street
okay right it's like Eyes Wide Shut okay
it's Absolut AB total opulence okay and
then when you're ready to fly you're
driven in you know Dr Evil's car which
of course isn't S-Class Mercedes with
the windows blacked out isn't it you
know okay which is kind of like you know
it's kind of like you know Dr Evil's
natural conveyance of choice okay you're
driven to the plane and you walk onto a
ryion air flight okay and the ryion air
flight cost you 37 quid and it cost 250
quid to use the lb you're a nightclub
promoter right yeah yeah we can go into
business doing this ready so the whole
idea is okay the bid on the plane is
only an hour it doesn't really matter if
it's Ryan Air and okay you know you
could do a thing where you book the
middle seat out okay so you got a bit of
space but basically you use Ryan Air and
the whole aim is you make the airport
experience amazing where you're
literally ferried to the plane then the
plane bit you don't try and compete
because there's a limit what you can do
at 30,000 ft to make it amazing yes
certainly a limit to what's ilal that
would make it what's legal that would
make it amazing is quite there are lots
of illegal things I'm sure you could do
make it amazing but we'll we'll kind of
you know we'll draw a veil over that
should we say yeah what so we were
talking earlier on about kind of this uh
culture of creativity that you guys have
managed to Foster and kind of perpetuate
as well I know that you've spoken to
Rick Rubin yes I yeah that was fantastic
yeah you think a lot about creativity
for yourself by the way Rick asked me a
question which I'm going to ask you he
said why haven't you moved to the United
States and you have moved to the United
States
now uh you've moved to Austin which I
think is very clever yeah because I
think Austin is actually an interesting
game which is Americans are choosing it
because they want to live within a cool
a cool culture rather than a cash
culture okay in a sense the status game
in Austin is slightly different you've
read that Paul Graham essay each City
Whispers something different to you
lovely yeah I I haven't but I will yeah
he's he's an interesting guy you know
you go to Miami Miami Whispers to you
you are as important as the watch on
your wrist or the shoes that you wear or
the car that you drive yeah right uh La
Whispers to you you are as important as
as your role in the entertainment
industry people that you know and the
people who know you know in La there's a
club which is only for people who don't
work in the entertainment industry right
because any other club they join they're
automatically at the bottom you can you
can own some business you know literally
a billion dollar business and you can
own it but in La if you go to the same
Club as the celebs you're basically
treated like fil second so they they
have a kind of separate club for people
who aren't in the film industry
fascinatingly and La you're right it
Whispers London's very complicated
because it's the bloody Center of
everything from government to
advertising to business to I can't
remember what he says London London
Whispers to you uh but yeah so the the
Rick Austin also has the great advantage
of being a democratic City in a
Republican state I people say that blue
dot red ocean thing I see no one that's
liberal everybody that's there is in
some degree based or conservative I
sorry really I that's what I see man I
mean I assumed that you know I assumed
it was my my idea of Heaven which is
kind of it's short range left wing and
long range rightwing which is so I can
go out and I can buy really good coffee
made by people with interesting body art
but then in the afternoon I can drive
into the desert and fire machine guns
and oil drums both of those things are
actually true yeah you can that's Austin
in a nut tank that is that is a Austin
in a nutshell but definitely one of the
things that's interest I absolutely
adore Texas so I I've been I've been
having the the odd dig at know I said I
got nothing against the United States my
cousin Woodrow was president of the
[__] place but um uh I have to say
that uh Texas I find absolutely love now
I'm a Brit I'm a white guy Etc actually
it seems to me I got a texting colleague
who says all Texans get on pretty well
because they're all Texans okay they
have an identity which transcends other
things okay now Austin you say that
actually you find oddly that you don't
find that kind of blue dot well I don't
know man it's just I don't know how much
of it's my visit there but I love D I
love Houston I love Dallas I don't know
how much of it's a selection effect
because the people that I'm around are
going to be people who have maybe
achieved a degree of Financial Freedom
that's caused them to lean more right or
whatever but there's definitely uh and
low taxes correct there's definitely a
freedom to and a freedom from culture so
there is a freedom to do the things that
I want and there is a freedom from any
of the [__] interventions of the
people from Washington etc etc but going
back to the creativity thing for the
people who want to try and get a uh they
want to artificially inseminate their
creativity muscle yes what are some of
the things that you advise the guys that
you work with and the companies you work
with to do to engender a creative
culture study biology not just sort of
physics and maths in other words study
complex things um I have a kind of weird
Theory which might form a chapter in my
next book which is in a weird kind of
way cops are better scientists than
scientists are okay now let me explain
okay if so one of the things I recommend
is read a lot of True Life crime okay
study that kind of stuff by the way
there's a fantastic Andrew Schulz uh
routine on this on his wife's propensity
to watch um films about serial killers
the female obsession with serial killers
is never going to make sense to me but
do you have because I have it as well so
it's great because my wife and I both I
think she likes it because there's a lot
of psychology and I like it because
someone gets killed but I'm only joking
Bond over your love of TR there is a
really interesting thing about reading
about um uh true life crime which is
it's one case where you get an
extraordinary amount of detailed study
into the life if you've read those you
know uh books about say Peter suck
Cliffe and his family you get an
extraordinary amount of detail into a
family which in many cases is completely
ordinary except for the obviously the
outlier that somebody kills somebody or
a lot of people so that you know you do
get that weird thing which is a very
deep study not into a major historical
figure except in the worst possible
sense um but but um no it is interesting
but what it is about detective work is
you're kind of working okay there's a
Conan dial P so actually funny enough
one of the I think one of the sources of
my creativity was obsessively reading
Sherlock Holmes short stories as a
fairly young kid okay my Behavioral
Science thing was probably weirdly
reading ESOP who uh is really the first
behavioral scientist even though he
lived in the 6th Century BC you know
Jesus was also a pretty good behavioral
scientist if you look at it you know the
parable of the lost sheep is basically
loss aversion okay you have really
interesting things like you know the
parable of the vineyard is you know
perceived Equity you know actually
there's a there's a hell of a lot of
Behavioral Science in Jesus um seriously
so that's that's my third book you know
there's that book Jane Austin was a game
theorist okay there's a fantastic book
my my my book's gonna be my third book's
gonna be Jesus was a behavioral
Economist right I wonder how that one's
going to go yeah yeah I don't know how
that's going to go down but um but
actually what what C do talks about
through the mouthpiece of Sherlock
Holmes is this business of reasoning
backwards and he said that everybody
knows how to reason forwards this has
happened so this is going to happen next
and it's the natural mode of thinking
reasoning backwards is not actually that
difficult to do but most people don't do
it and that is if you think about a
detective uh a work of detection it's
this thing has happened now we have to
find out what were the pre-existing
conditions that led to this outcome and
in advertising forward in creativity
it's we want to get to this place in the
words of Roger L Martin a very brilliant
business Guru what would have to be true
for this to come
about I think that's the question by the
way a lot of political movements don't
ask they they have a hypothesized ideal
future okay and they don't subtly ask
the question okay what needs to happen
between now and in other words play the
hand your dealt we happen to be here we
want to get there let's not just ignore
Where We Are and immediately effectively
fantasize into existence a perfectly
neat uh Society because change doesn't
work like that you have to start where
you are you have to play the hand your
Del yes you it's very very easy to say
why did it take them so long to you know
uh give votes for women etc etc but
actually if you look at the reality of
it these things take
time and also persuasion is slower than
legislation but it's persuasion that
actually makes things work have you got
the so I'll just make that distinction
with in regard to drink driving okay the
breathalyzer you know penalty points
license banss for driving for American
Americans we don't have a distinct
between driving under the influence and
driving while intoxicated if you're
basically intoxicated you lose your
license
okay it the legislation sort of worked
but a lot of people in my parents
generation thought it was a bit naughty
to get caught over the limit my parents
didn't drive drunk I just want to
absolve them of that but some of their
contemporaries did and my parents
wouldn't stop someone leaving the house
if they' had too much to drink they'd
encourag them to stay but they wouldn't
like grab their car keys now when
something makes it way its way from
being imposed to being adopted what you
see in my children's generation is they
would wrestle one of their friends to
the ground before they got into a car
over the limit so America is so
different to this I know so different
the attitude of Americans to people that
drink Drive is like you'll be at some
bar or something so oh we're going to go
to such and such a place
do you want to come I was oh right okay
brilliant presuming that there's an Uber
waiting outside and someone gets into
the Ford F150 go I've just watched you
syn Three Margaritas over the last hour
and no one no one really bats an I I saw
this amazing video I'll find it in LA is
like that as well la la yeah yeah I mean
Uber has probably reduced this to some
degree but the extent to which people
used to drive around La intoxic my
brother-in-law who lived there for quite
a few years just couldn't get his head
rounded at all yeah there was a a great
video of when they first introduced the
uh you can't drink and drive drink and
drive not drink then drive you can't
drink and drive and they're talking to
these guys and and girls from the deep
south in America and they're all in you
know beat up Chevy trucks or whatever
and they're interviewing them through
the window and this dude sat there and
there's another one with a woman who sat
there child on passenger seat without
seat belt on beer between legs saying I
don't know what this country is coming
to that a guy can't finish his hard day
at work and you know have a beer when
he's on his way home you know this
country is being run by Communists these
godamn commies trying to take our beers
away from us and I'm like you're
drinking and driving literally drinking
and driving extraordinary thing I think
in New Orleans or certainly Louisiana I
think is it isn't it where you can
actually have drive-thru margarita
stands phenomenal so you literally put a
margarita in your cup holder nothing in
America is beyond being drive-through
the bank
CVS [__] Margaritas everything is
drive-through that that by the way um I
never answered Rick rubin's question why
I never moved to the United States and
there are two reasons one of which is
I'd probably make a million dollars but
then I'd start shopping at Whole Foods
and I'd be back to where I
started right okay so the one thing I
can't get my head [__] individual
malthusian trap that you've got yourself
into we had this La guy who came over
and he was La creative guy wonderful guy
and he was in raptures about waitr now
this won't be funny to American audience
apologies okay but he said the food is
such good quality and such reasonable
prices okay and you suddenly realize he
grown up on Whole Foods or Bristol Farms
or those LA and it's completely bipolar
American Grocery retail you know German
grocery retail is all about price really
y okay American Grocery retail British
grocery retail is really all about brand
actually quite interesting and then you
have American Grocery retail which is
just like you have a choice between two
absurd extremes you it's like having
first class and standing room only you
know it's kind of weird I think what
happens with British supermarkets is
that they are woven into the class
structure as well yeah right you know
little our system isn't all bad you know
let me explain this okay one thing which
I think is problematic about the British
class system but is also quite nice okay
is you do reach escape velocity
relatively soon okay if you prove
yourself reasonably successful
materially okay so okay this is a total
St stereotype okay but if you're a BRD
you you're going to do this right okay
you're going to come back to the Britain
with some money which I hope you've made
in the colonies okay right slow and
you're going to buy the old rectory in
Minion Hampton a flat in London you'll
have a Range Rover a labrador um a wife
called Polly and two children at private
school a membership to Soho House
basically that point you can stop okay
because anything more than that is
actually evidence that makes you
suspicious you're probably a drug dealer
you know if you got a private jet or
something like that people go he's
probably up to no good okay he's
probably a bit Shady he's not really
respectable and so there is that kind of
weird thing probably which is the the
royal family sumptuary laws which is you
know because we had a royal family who
actually in many ways their Pleasures
until recently were extraordin walking
around muddy fields in Wellington okay
yeah there's a c there's a culture of
sort of elite modesty in some ways in
the UK you know look at a Land Rover
Defender
yeah it's it's a every single person I
have a weird thought in the car market
which is once you produce the Electric
Land Rover Defender there can be no more
prestigious vehicle than that in a weird
way why because
it's it's hard to explain but the landro
defender is unbelievably beautiful by
the way the latest iteration of it is
fantastic if you made that electric and
therefore you know you've got a big
tough versatile vehicle big heavy thing
with a huge battery quite a lot of range
the per performance is going to be fine
right because it's electric okay and
generally it doesn't matter what the
electric car is the performance is going
to be great okay why would if you had
the money why would you have any other
vehicle okay and the only other vehicle
I can imagine by the way is um will a
proportional so I'm as a georgist I
believe that there should be a single
land value tax and I believe that an
awful lot of Technology exists so that
people can escape from the rent seeking
depredations of land Lords and land
owners and that's one of the great
advantages of places like Texas okay
you've got it super abundance because
Austin like say Vegas or like say
Phoenix okay they were basically built
after the car was invented okay so
living eight miles from the center of
Phoenix doesn't matter because you can
just drive in it's retrofited to have
the automobile in Phoenix what I love
about do you ever do you ever go there
Phoenix Scottdale Santa Fe is a
fantastic I'm going to Scottdale in a
couple of weeks time for the first time
St the hotel Valley Ho okay it's kind of
hotel where the Rat Pack would have hung
out it's really really cool and fun okay
but I I absolutely love the place now
bear in mind okay as a Brit okay the two
most pointless cities in the United
States to visit in New York and San
Francisco because they're a crap attempt
to recreate a European city whereas
Brits love places like Austin or Houston
or LA or Chicago because they're really
different they allow you to have a
completely different life to the life
you'd have in London and I'm going to
make an accusation okay deep down
everybody wants to live in Suburbia okay
but in Britain living in Suburbia isn't
cool but if you live in LA you can go
and buy effectively a Suburban House you
know up in the kind of you know just off
what what's that place called um um uh
Wonderland you know the valley thing
that goes up towards um uh uh the the
mhall drive yeah yeah you can basically
live in a glorious Suburban house
because his La it's totally cool okay so
that's one of those little games you see
if you move to Beckley Heath your
friends would start disowning you right
if you move to LA and buy a nice
Suburban House totally different yeah so
I was thinking about uh the Rebrand of
it's speaking about that sort of West
Coast phenomenon this Rebrand of Twitter
to X what's your assessment of it's a
very weird thing to do because I would
wait until he creates the everything app
before you Rebrand it yeah um that's
what seems strange to me bundle
neuralink and SpaceX bundle payment
vehicles I mean If he if he bu I'll
forgive him everything if he builds in a
Content payment mechanism to Twitter
how' you mean uh there is a fundamental
there there are lots of holes in the
ecosystem the digital ecosystem which
haven't been plugged because they're
natural monopolies and therefore um it's
very difficult for them to reach
critical mass as Network Goods unless
they have Monopoly status now looking at
the Royal Mail which is the first real
Network good the penny post technically
not the Royal Male okay the penny post
was an extraordinary thing because there
had been one penny postal services in
London for about 150 years and this guy
Roland Hill with the mathematical help
of Charles Babbage IE the kind of
inventor of the computer and one of the
10 greatest mathematicians of his time
managed to do the maths to say actually
you can scale this up to a national and
subsequently an imperial level so
there's an imperial Penny post in 1910
whatever you know austral when ra it
didn't include Australia and New Zealand
you had to pay extra for them but India
but included India so when ramanujan
wrote to GH Hardy in Cambridge he paid a
penny for the letter okay wow now the
mathematics there is to say that in a
network of of the postal kind of network
the G the efficiencies in trunk routes
in other words the cost per mile when
you're transporting uh 50,000 letters at
a time the cost per mile is so low that
all the costs basically are in
collection sortation and then last mile
delivery so as a consequence the
distance is actually more or less
irrelevant to the cost of carriage and
therefore we can have a flat rate for
postage and it required babage to do the
maths to prove it worked even then it
lost money for the first few years
because people weren't in the habit of
writing to people 500 miles away because
they didn't know anybody okay apart from
you know takes some time it's bit like
if you own the world's first fax machine
it's not really very useful okay and I
think there are lots of things and I
think two of them are a locker system
for e-commerce delivery and what the
government should do is basically
license them Monopoly for 10 years and
say okay if you offer an Open Access
locker system will give you 10 to 15
years of schumpeterian rent from your
your Monopoly okay and by the way it has
to be open access so that local local
shops I can ring up a local shop in
Seven Oaks okay and say can you drop off
a copy of this book in my locker or in
this Locker you know sometime this
evening after you shut right not just
not just e-commerce but actually all
forms of local Commerce and indeed
peer-to-peer sending if I want to send
something to my dad if there's a locker
in his village he's 93 I can basically
pop it in my locker and it'll be sent to
his because then you remove the last
mile cost of delivery which is causing
environmental costs it's causing
Transportation congestion and it's also
it's not ultimately scalable because as
I spoke to someone at PNG about the
delivery the subscription model for
things like razors they own Gillette
right and they said the problem with
this model is it works at a limited
extent but if we bought everything that
way our home our homes would turn into a
delivery Hub you know it your house
becomes the logistics Hub and every time
you open the window it's beep beep beep
beep okay it just doesn't make sense at
ultimate scale it doesn't make what this
got to do with Twitter and X right okay
so there's a similar problem which is
with micro payments for now I've got a
friend called Dominick young who's in a
company called axate which is also
looking at this problem which is most
people don't want to subscribe to most
content okay pay to subscribe okay now
there isn't a single case there may be
one case in like Finland okay but that's
it there is there's barely a single case
in the world of a tabloid newspaper
making a success of the subscription
model what Twitter could do is launch a
micro payment system where I keep like
20 quid of my um Twitter balance and
every time I want to read an article in
well I do subscribe to the New York
Times but I don't subscribe to the Wall
Street Journal and i' bugged if I'm
going to subscribe to the Ft right
because the Ft there are lots of
articles in the Ft I'd pay a pound to
read but I'm not paying 35 quid a month
or whatever I mean most people claim the
Ft I guess or at least it's tax
deductible okay but also the Ft there's
a there's a psychological thing going on
here which is that there are C certain
things in the Ft which I would love to
read there's some fantastic journalists
there what's the guy called garish
something or other brilliant guy
okay um but equally if I pay 40 quid a
month for the whole of the Ft or
whatever it costs that's 500 quid a year
right okay well I feel that you know 70%
80% of that money is going to produce
articles on the prospects for Central
banking reform in Ecuador which are of
no interest to me at all right I'm not
sure they that much interest to Ft
readers but but nonetheless okay I I
don't want to pay for the stuff I don't
want and it's a psychological thing even
if the net value to me of each of those
articles added together might add up to
20s I'm not paying for the whole thing
because I feel I'm paying for a lot of
value that I that other people are
getting but I'm not so if you centralize
the payment ability through Twitter you
could then I keep my Twitter balance at
20 quid or 20 US dollar and I go that ft
article looks a bit interesting I'll pay
50 cents to read that yeah now you can
really monetize high quality and the
same goes for video content by the way
the same could go for musical content
okay although spotify's made that work
fairly well but I think for high quality
journalism in particular but equally
tabloid journalism PE the people who buy
the sun buy it in the way you buy
chocolate or crisps or a packet of
cigarettes right an Impulse bar next to
the tail and you go oh I feel like a bit
of a treat I'll buy a copy of the super
sore away sun and it's XP and then you
take it with you those same people do
not want to just just as there are
people who will only have pay as you go
mobile phones even if they would be
better off on a contract okay um I won't
buy I won't buy a train season ticket
because my argument is there are two
days of the week where I don't take the
standard Journey now I might actually
save money overall on the three Journeys
I do take but it pisses me off that I'm
getting proportionately worse value than
the people who travel in 5 days a week
but I'm still paying the same so that
feeling of pissed offness pre prevents
me from subscribing to a season ticket
and it prevents me from subscribing to a
lot of Publications where I would give
them 10 quid a month if it was pay as
you go so would you if you had been El
Al also by the way if you if I subscribe
to every publication that you know I I
think I subscrib to the Atlantic I think
I subscribed to the New Yorker but let's
add okay wired New York Magazine let's
adders the new States okay I do
subscribe to the spec I write for The
Spectator so that's obviously free
exactly and I subscribe to the times and
the telegraph I think okay and then I
read you're probably accumulating what
at least a grand a year well well this
is the point that I I've basically
reached Peak subscription okay
subscription saturation so in other
words there is a limit to the number of
direct debits people are prepared to
have yeah and therefore you cannot grow
the market for paid high quality content
or paid entertainment content tell you
what's an interesting business that I
found out about recently I think it's
called Rocket reach and this company
they go through maybe you link them to
your bank or something I don't really
know how it works uh but they go through
and they look at all of the debits that
you you that you've got that are kind of
lapsed or pointless or [__] something
like that and they get rid of them yeah
so if you've been El by the way I'd also
I would also add legislation here which
is it is too difficult to cancel a
recurring credit card payment I was
paying for Club Penguin for my kids you
know when I was picking them up pissed
from all bar one you know at 1:00 in the
morning okay I was still paying for Club
bloody penguin
no I mean you know I probably had a
little sneaky visit to I didn't don't
worry um uh but
um I did not go on Club P the only time
I went on Club Penguin as an adult is my
children when they were younger would
make me play the games to earn points to
decorate their Igloo fantastic so they'd
Outsource to me to get me to play the
dad go to work please virtually yeah I
wasn't doing anything else I don't want
to end up in the nonsense wing of
Wakefield prison okay um I wasn't going
on for any other purpose
okay [__] hell look let's get back to
X for me get back to X if you'd been
Elon would you have waited until you
were able to bundle everything
underneath right yeah because there's
too much equity in and nobody everybody
refers to it as Twitter brackets X
there's a hell of a lot of equity in
that it made perfect sense as a name you
had a tweet it's a very very bizarre
decision of Elon I mean he you know
undoubtedly you know qu I mean the most
bizarre feature of Elon okay if may say
so which is if you take a comedic
Viewpoint one of the great things you do
you take this sort of Darwin mentality
where you look at little things and
suddenly you discover these absurdities
everywhere and elon's greatest absurdity
okay is he's in favor of dous cars but
mans space travel now I don't want to be
rude okay what he means by man space
travel is people who have no obvious
aeronautic ability should be able to
project themselves as humans into space
but C cars which obviously benefit from
being driven by a human have to drive
around autonomously now I don't want to
be rude but isn't that the wrong way
around okay shouldn't cars be driven by
people and spacecraft be autonomous I
don't want to be you know how much input
do the humans in spacecraft have now
none my brother is an astrophysicist if
you want to get astronomers and
astrophysicists absolutely um driven to
a point of apoplexy just mention man
space travel okay because they regard it
as per per dollar Ben an extraordinarily
bad way of discovering things about the
universe you should just be robots it
was described by one uh colleague of my
brothers as spending $300
million to find out how mice wank in
zerog okay you know the kind of
experiments you performed on man space
travel are kind of absurd compared to
something like you know Space Telescope
or or something of that kind you know
whereas if you look at what those probes
do that you know nonhuman probes it back
it's just that that's just joyous
absolutely joyous however I do have a
colleague in the advertising industry
Trevor Bey whose lifetime dream has been
to go into space and I think he's done
this with Virgin I get it what is it now
250 Grand I think that that was it yeah
and he all credit him he's not some rich
diletante guy who decided it' be cool I
mean he's probably quite rich but he
he's been an absolute lifetime space
obsessive uh literally since being a
child so it's a it's perfectly good use
of his I can see why he does that each
time that we speak you have become an
evangelist for a new category of
products I think this is maybe your
fifth or sixth time on the show yeah
each time that we've spoken I feel like
the first time was the Japanese toilet
the second time air fryers the air I was
the John the Baptist of bloody air
fryers I can tell you that much right I
mean seriously I went to Phillips who at
the time had a monopoly of air on of air
frers now this isn't really interesting
point for anybody who's got a business
the thing to look at at a business is
not just the rate of growth okay you can
have extraordinary rates of growth which
consist of lots of people trying
something and deciding it's [__] I mean
if you compare that thing what was that
Facebook thing threads right now if you
look at the actual data for the the
adoption of threads it was absolutely
you know exponential rates of insane
adoption if you go there it's basically
you know [__] Wast abs Wasteland okay
now the reason for that is it made they
made it very very easy to sign up people
had a look didn't like it you can't
actually leave threads because if you
want to leave threads you got to delete
your Instagram account which
understandably people don't want to do
so that's a kind of furline trap okay
now it looks impressive means nothing by
contrast there are things which grow
very very slowly at first it's a sigmoid
curve the data you need to look at to
give yourself reassurance if that data
is there is the repeat purchase rate or
the subsequent conversion to evangelism
yes not many people had air frers now I
I had this even the reason I went to
Phillips and they didn't listen and I
said look s trust me you're sitting on
an effing gold mine here if you just
promote your they were the only
manufacturer of air fryers at the time
okay if you promote your air fryer and
you advertise it you can create kind of
mve were they not promoting it at all no
not at all didn't advertise it at all I
have no clue I don't know what that it
drove me nuts well it's now ninja right
ninja ninja nin wasn't ninja wasn't TF
wasn't there now ninja has become the um
the Tesla they have I've got a I've got
a 450 XL I've got a 450l a double is
that a double no single single yeah it's
single but extra big and it goes to 450
so here's my I'm sure that you've got
done this already look at me teaching
the teaching the Messiah how to use his
own [__] air fryer um from frozen
steak salt the [__] out of it 12 minutes
either side slap it on a plate done
perfectly every time I asked I want I
needed to eat more red meat in my diet
according to my dietitian uh so I asked
the only person I know who eats a very
very high volume of meat Michaela
Peterson who only eats meat yeah that's
a bit weird isn't it I mean I I have to
say
Okay I I my attitude to Jordan Peterson
is a bit the same as my attitude to
Frankie Bo which is in small doses I
quite like him but I think he's
overcommitted to a particular dogma and
I think what what he says and there are
very interesting insights to be derived
from him but I wonder that there's a
phrase that was used of Enoch Powell
this equally applies to people on the
left okay which is you're driven mad by
the remorselessness of your own logic
okay
and I don't think I don't think anybody
should see the world through exclusively
a lens of black and white left or right
okay I just don't think it's helpful
conducive to problem solving an example
on the left will be James O'Brien of
someone who's you know I call it James
O'Brien jesuitism which is that you
you're so obsessed with the rightness of
your cause that you effectively
construct an argument from a fairly
dubious assumption and arrive at a place
and therefore you go QED my position on
this is incontestable okay and what
what's less visible about that is that
the starting point or the driving
assumption or Axiom of your argument
isn't that great your argument seems
wonderfully convincing it's a bit like
dating sites okay every time make I've
never been on a date just in case my
wife's I don't want you you know I don't
I don't know what dating side I go on in
terms of you know fat Welshman there's
probably a niche there isn't there I
guess um but in any case by the way you
mentioned that asymmetry that you said
astoundingly that in your entire time as
a nightclub promoter and as I assume
because I can't tell as a BL a pretty
good-look guy who was on love Island by
the way which is partly a wpp creation
so we can take a small amount of credit
by the the way for your incredibly
deserved uh elevation and fame but you
you've only actually been spontaneously
approached by a woman three time twice
was it yeah yeah twice
twice that overcoming of approach
anxiety for women guides talk about how
hard it is to go up to women and that's
true that that is true but for a girl to
do it to a guy they need to swallow
something else which is that if they are
rejected they've had to overcome a a
social convention that is is very very
embarrassing to have done to be reject
it's the same reason it's the reverse
reason actually of why uh women are
shamed for um not women ashamed of not
for not performing in bed in a different
way to manner but men get shamed for not
always being hot to trot when the wife
is for some reason if you as a guy the
guy is always supposed to be that's the
Jimmy car joke isn't it that men and
women desire sex to the same extent the
difference is if a woman wants sex it
actually happens I think that's a Jimmy
car I don't disagree
go back to let's let's round out this
evangelist thing so we had we had a
Japanese toilet we had uh the air I do I
do take my Darwinism very literally
which is don't don't have a sense of
proportion don't get worried about being
distracted okay I imagine on the Beagle
the guy you know the guy spent 10 years
of his life [__] around with
earthworms for God's sake right Mustang
Macky which may become Mustang macki
GT uh what was the other thing there was
something you got for your dad a
telephone with massive buttons no that
that was a very interesting thing which
was that um the idea of Designing for
the disabled yeah is actually a good
business policy even because you will
actually find yourself with a target
audience far larger than the one you
originally anticipated who got it's it's
rather like actually you know glutenfree
okay the number of people who are
actually gluten intolerant to the extent
of having celiac disease is pretty small
but there are hell of a lot of people
who are trying to avoid gluten who will
also buy a gluten free product and in
the same way what Ian the example I
always give is you know disability
legislation mandates wheelchair ramps
they're also handy if you've got wheelie
luggage they mandate door handles rather
than door knobs because people who have
bad arthritis can't use a door knob but
actually if you're carrying two bugs of
tea you can open a door handle with your
elbow because when you're carrying two
bags of tea you effectively lost the use
of your hands and you know putting the
shampoo bottle that opens at the top and
the conditioner that opens at the bottom
You could argue that's just for people
with severe visual impairment but
actually no cuz I'm in the shower I've
got severe visual impairment itless I've
had your fancy laser eye surgery which I
can see everything so presumably you can
see everything I can't see a [__]
thing what have you be what are you
evangelizing about at the moment um
that's very interesting um actually
electric cars interest me a lot because
one I mean one of the things that
interest me is that if you work in the
advertising industry it practices what
is makes it very very interesting is
that it's as I said it's problem solving
methodology is slightly odd it's not the
standard scientific you know we must
have complete certainty P value less
than 0.05 before we proceed it's closer
to detective work which is you might act
on a hunch because the hunch or the
little bit of anecdotal information
doesn't give you a decisive answer but
it tells you uh what to investigate more
okay it tells you where to direct your
attention now if I had time I don't know
how much time I've got there are two
extraordinary stories here about how the
capture of Levi bellfield uh effectively
ghastly serial killer effectively
happened because a former girlfriend of
bellfields uh wrote to the police I
think or contented them and said I had
this boyfriend once and there was a copy
of a magazine and all the blonde women
had had their faces defaced with a brro
okay now there's no evidential value to
that you can't bang someone up for 20
years for defacing a copy of Vogue well
that probably wasn't Vogue I not sure
the bellfield household quite of
stretched to Harpers and queen or
anything you know but whatever magazine
it was right and you can't arrest
someone for that but you should
investigate okay similar thing happened
with the Yorkshire Ripper which is uh
effectively there was a very shrewd cop
and I can't remember his name Yorkshire
cop relatively Junior and the Yorkshire
police were obsessed with the idea that
he had a Newcastle accent do you
remember this yes cuz you had that fake
those fake tape sent in which the police
the police wrongly believed that there
was information in the Sunland
technically they narrowed it down to
some pit Village Shields yeah some
[__] pit Village that what was
extraordinary there was an accent expert
who placed him to within five streets
that was the unbelievable thing about
the accidents of the Northeast they have
that degree of J but he wasn't the
actual
perpetrator and one day this couple they
have to go and interview people who are
suspects largely because their car is
regularly cited in the red light
district of Leeds or Bradford okay and
or else they have some other reason to
raise sup Mission okay and they
routinely have to go and interview these
couples and it's an awful thing to do
because first of all you've got to get
the wife out of the room so you can ask
the husband why he's always in the red
light district okay so you have to go oh
my throat's like sandpaper make us a cup
of tea love but they started this couple
of cops just started with this kind of
break the ice riff which was right Madam
now's your chance to put your husband
away for good to get rid of your husband
for good and so they made light of the
fact that they were making inquiries
into the Yorkshire Ripper but by
starting with a joke they kind of
detoxified the whole exchange okay they
were saying don't worry you know he's
not you know you know you don't need to
panic it was a wonderful little joke you
know now has your chance to get rid of
your husband okay
and every single person they played that
joke on about 10% of them got angry and
90% of them laughed as you might expect
okay some people just don't have a sense
of humor um which is what slightly weird
about woke comedy which is you allow
comedians to be policed by people with
absolutely no sense of humor whatsoever
which doesn't seem to make much sense
yes um but they just don't have they
don't have a sense of humor when they
interviewed suck Cliff that was the only
occasion where they told that joke and
they didn't either laugh or get angry
they just took it as a dead B kind of
statement of fact now then they noticed
okay he had a gap in his teeth he was a
lorry driver the pattern of wear on his
Footwear because you're a long-distance
Lorry driver match some footprints that
have been found near the scene and they
immediately went up to the head of the
inquiry and said we should look at this
guy and then the guy said does he have a
Jordi accent no he's a local man right
forget it and they this guy really
bollocked them for being suspicious I
don't want I don't want to see anybody I
don't want to see anybody without a
Jordy axon basically yeah Y and um uh so
now what's interesting about that is
it's as I said it's reverse reasoning
it's kind of okay and also it involves
to some extent a degree of nose I think
there's something in this I'm not quite
sure what but let's explore it a bit
further now you might argue
you maybe that's how we should actually
pursue some pharmaceutical research
there's a company called helex in
Cambridge which effectively is aiming to
do pharmaceutical research backwards
which is find interesting compounds and
see what they treat rather than Define a
narrow disease and find a way to treat
it now it's what you might call post-
rationalized science rather than pre-ra
science now a lot of advertising Works
through that way it works backwards
which is you come up with some weird
idea through some mental process of
inspir that you're not quite sure about
and then you reverse engineer the
reasons why it might work now a lot of
people see that as cheating just as the
German you know German said well you
know we designed a a drug to treat
angina and it makes people penises erect
okay this is clearly a failure okay well
actually no it's the right answer to a
different question and it worries me
that we
discount we discount it so often when we
come up with an interesting answer to a
different question now now the
advertising industry is probably
relatively tolerant of that you know you
know I always say look don't apologize
for post rationalization if it's an
answer it's an answer okay how you got
there this isn't like a high school
maths exam where you have to show you're
working out okay and sometimes the the
place you get is by the way weird I
always say look in psychological issues
in physics the opposite of a good idea
is wrong but in Psychology the opposite
of a good idea might be another good
idea okay it's a bit like the difference
between you know if you like policing
conversation on the one hand and Andrew
Schultz on the other okay they're
complete opposites but they may actually
in a weird way be you know Solutions in
some kind of strange way and we you know
the psychology of humor is kind of
fascinating because it is kind of
harmless play I mean you know all
primates all mammals kind of engage in
kind of play fighting and we do it
verbally as well as physically you know
I'm not going to start wrestling with
you now that'll be completely weird okay
but we can engage in a bit of verbal
banter yes and you know and it's kind of
like you know the tone is that there's
also a form that abuse forms in
friendship and Brit British English is
slightly more High context than American
English is in that not that Americans
don't do it but British English is very
much you say the opposite understatement
that in other words tone of voice
determines meaning or context determines
meaning more than it does in American
English uh that's not me speaking that's
an American by the way it might be J
from
height and so that kind of verbal play
which is you know if we weren't friends
I wouldn't be able to be rude to you
like this you know which is kind of
again it's kind of reverse reasoning but
those kind of games exist all over the
place which means that actually the
opposite of something can can be just as
valuable as the thing itself if you like
and I you know I think it's important in
problem solving because I think it's an
additional string to your bow just as I
think that that solving problems
psychologically rather than
technologically is is an extra string to
your bow in terms of uh you know solving
uh difficult problems make the railway
enjoyable don't make the railway fast
Etc okay I think that's an extra that
expands the solution space and this
business of allowing people to imagine
and then work backwards which according
to um uh interestingly the scientific
method and and of course the method of
scientific funding would be in unless
you've identified an absolutely clear
problem you're not allowed to do
anything okay right you just experiment
now you'll get some funding because you
have demonstrated the absolute Clarity
of your way ahead and the single point
of your destination okay now if you look
at someone like Andre gim who came up
with graphine you know now okay first of
all he discovered graphine with
equipment that you could have bought
from Staples or wh Smiths okay which is
just taking taking bits of pencil
graphite and endlessly pulling them
apart with a bit of
Cotate but he actually himself says I
don't like that kind of research I like
kind of what he calls hitandrun research
where you just find an interesting angle
of inquiry and piss around for a bit and
see where it gets you and then you
discover the use subsequently I think
that's a good strategy I think that's a
strategy I just wonder I just wonder
about our world where you have to win an
argument before you can act in other
words you need approval from complicated
bodies of people before you can do
anything you've got this thing about how
all creatives have to justify their
ideas to rationalists but no rationalist
have to do it the other way around Rory
let's bring this one home mate we've got
lunch to get to with okay and George
every single time you come on I
absolutely love it thank you for joining
me what can people expect the next
couple of months well we'll catch up
again but can I also say I mean nothing
gives me more pleasure than to see how
this entire series is just flourishing
and absolutely brilliant I think it's
it's and and there's a great quote from
Jimmy Carr on your interview where he
says YouTube became the biggest T TV
station in the world and nobody noticed
and I think by the way you know we'd be
wrong if we didn't kind of end with a
bit of a pin there's a wonderful article
in the Ft saying that you know YouTube
is the jewel in the crown of the
internet uh one of the things I
recommend to everybody by the way you
said what am I evangelizing for I'll
tell you YouTube premium oh okay
subscribe to YouTube premium and
secondly watch YouTube on your TV right
yep I don't understand okay my kids
right they want to watch they for [__]
sake right okay everybody in your whole
childhood was how big is your Telly yeah
okay there's by the way a lovely joke
about that which is okay which is
wonderful thing which is only of value
to Brit so I really apologize so Kenneth
Williams mom was obviously pretty
similar to Kevin Williams because they
were sitting backstage waiting for some
filming to finish on a carry on film and
um uh someone said to uh their neighbor
which is one of the other relatives of
Charles hry or something you know what
television have you got I've got a
14inch console to which Kenneth Williams
replied Kenneth Williams mom replied 14
inches that'll be enough to console
anyone okay so clearly there was a kind
of family tradition of absolute smut now
people are watching it on their phone
but we all competed for how big your
Telly was and then I have these kids who
are staring at this sort of pathetic
little letter box watch it on your big
watch YouTube on your big Telly it's
broadcast quality nearly all of it it's
4K there's 250,000 hours of content
where I think the title starts with the
words how to yeah okay if you want to
repair now what I think has
happened is first of all we've had we've
had several YouTube Revolutions in that
well several things okay there is a
problem with certain Technologies which
is when they're new they're not quite
good enough so they hit the hype cycle
at the wrong Point yeah uh that was true
of video conferencing okay when it was
when it was it when it was hyped it was
a bit [__] and by the time it stopped
being [__] it was too late to Hype it
because you looked a bit like that guy
in the fast show when isn't electricity
brilliant you know premature problem
premature problem okay and I think that
happened a bit with YouTube you know it
was a bit sort of flaky it was all
filmed on crappy phone cameras you know
it was all a bit pixelated wobbly and
now actually it is the it is the only
part of the internet which has no annoy
if you have the YouTube premium it has
no annoying qualities to it at all no
and the algorithm is [__] hot if I if I
keep on following you around the
internet I'll consider that a a win Rory
I love you to bits thank you very much
for likewise Mutual thank you very much
for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode with Rory you will love my full
length conversation with Douglas Murray
that you can watch right here go on give
it a tap